yes
okay welcome committee members and
members the public uh to the hearings we
have established here for the education
committee today a few notices for the
education committee first
um
i i'll try to meet with the leadership
today in regard to when we can determine
when we might have that week off that
we've been talk i've been talking about
i've been aiming all along for the week
that's in conjunction with the week off
down in the southern part of the state
here with schools i think that's the
28th going forward
um
also that means we're going to have to
really do a lot of exacting bills uh
judiciary the other day
exact 41 bills in one day
it can be done if we work together and
try to get things done but that's in
education that would be kind of like
i i wouldn't go to the bet on any of
that
i i would think that we'd be lucky to
get half of what they got done
and but we're going to certainly give it
a shot along the way here so today we
have some bills scheduled the first one
on the docket is 1638
relative to grievances under the right
to freedom from discrimination in public
workplaces and education representative
alessandro alessandro del orenzo
i get lou mixed up in here
um
is here to present the bill welcome so
rick before we get
before we get started on this and and um
and if i could just uh beg the pardon
from uh from the representative
uh on this i just um wanted to um
mention a couple things first of all um
uh we all appreciate the um the
notification
and the decency that um to to do that um
that uh representative ford uh provided
us over there if we're gonna be talking
about the mass no no no no no i just i
just i just really we really appreciate
the fact that that that he indicated to
all of all of our members that he had
tested covered positive so we should not
be indicating any specific person here
in in public well he he did it he did i
know he's done it but i don't want us to
be doing it here on the committee level
okay that's that's fine
i appreciate that um
but uh what what we're unclear about is
is if such notification one such
notification happens
uh what uh what that does to our
protocol
for both members of the committee as
well as guests
as far as as far as covid mitigation
okay i think what you need to do is take
that up with your leadership and they
can take up a leadership as this a
hearing we've got to move forward right
now okay thank you you're welcome
okay so we have 1638 welcome
representative
thank you mr chairman and thank you
honorable members of this committee
i introduce hb 1638
which seeks to change the grievance
procedure for violations of the right to
freedom from discrimination
in education
the proposed bill is simple
it aims to keep the grievance procedure
within the local school administrative
unit
a person agreed by an act made unlawful
by this sub division shall file a
written complaint to the district
superintendent of the sau
the petitioner would complete the public
education intake
form found on the department of
education website
the sa youth superintendent will use
this information to determine whether
the
petitioner has the basis to file a
formal charge after reviewing the
questionnaire the sau superintendent
will contact the aggrieved party to
gather further information
and as necessary
either explain
the next steps in filing a formal charge
or explain why
the person does not have a basis to file
a charge of discrimination
i believe that the local school district
should be in charge of the investigation
they are the head administrator of the
school district and have knowledge of
the teachers the parents and the
students
we need to trust that local
administrators
will complete a thorough investigation
and will without prejudice decide on
whether
the basis of the complaint has merit
this process is simple
quick and cheap
and the end result could be a learning
process for all involved
now if the aggrieved party disagrees
with the sau's finding they may appeal
to the new hampshire department of
education
the
doe will refer the case to the new
hampshire human rights commission or the
attorney general
alternatively the agreed party may file
a complaint in superior court or with
the u.s department of education office
of civil rights civil rights
and with that i close my testimony thank
you thanks charlotte and i'm open for
questions thank you are there any
questions represent like us
my question is what if it's the
superintendent is one of the people that
the
parents feel
are responsible or
they're the ones discriminating well i
haven't broken that out
i am open to an amendment that would
clarify that
thank you very much thank you good
question
further further questions from the
committee yes represent woodcock
thank you chairman good morning
representative good morning we're over
here
anyhow okay uh my question is i'm
looking at line five
of the
proposal yes and i'm just concerned
about the three days receipt time
where
it doesn't stipulate school days
my concern
comes in on friday
and then the
lack of time will make money they really
won't be a legitimate
time you repeat that i'm sorry sure um
i'm because on line five i'm concerned
about the
the time frame okay you have three days
after we see the complaint right but if
a complaint comes in on a thursday or
friday
it's monday the weekend's all gone
that's just three days so it doesn't
stipulate school days or business days
is that
that's that's just like i'm raising that
question was the reason that you omitted
that
no
um
it wasn't intentional um
to leave out
you know whether it's business days or
school days but it makes sense that it
would be uh school days okay thank you
very much thank you chairman you're
welcome uh i've got a question is that
applicable to to the
15 days are those school days or the
all days
those would be all days thank you
represent cordelia
thank you mr chairman um thank you
representative um just wondering if
the intent here is that
um before
um
c
before an action can be initiated um
with the
office of human rights the commission of
human rights
is the intent that
the person would have to go through a
local review of their complaint before
going to
the human rights commission
yes
thank you
further further questions from the
committee
not seeing any hands thank you very much
thank you
you're welcome
are there any other uh cards for this
okay thank you very much with that we'll
okay
you
um
a little small restaurant yeah excellent
breakfast okay you said you need to go
to the appliance breakfast all day it's
like five doors down
or something like that
yeah yeah
hey excellent all homemade it was great
yep
did you guys have any good burgers at
the barley house just drink yeah
oh i i i tried to contain myself yeah
there's always the one that doesn't go
wrong with a crowd
or something
yeah
microsoft
you
thank you
i think we're uh
ready to get started again
and our
next bill
is house bill 1090
relative to teaching on discrimination
in public schools
and the prime spencer dealer
representative di lorenzo is here and
thank you mr share and honorable members
of this committee
i am representative charlotte dilorenzo
and i represent new fields in new market
in rockingham district 17.
hb 1090
relative to teaching
on discrimination in public schools
now hb 1090
proposes to repeal and replace
rsa 93 colon 440
with affirming language
that is consistent with the education
laws of new hampshire which recognize
the need to provide diverse educational
approaches to instruction and curriculum
tailored to meet students needs
nothing entitled
x5 of the new hampshire revised statute
shall be construed as barring any person
employed by a public school district
school administrative unit
or public academy
for subjecting them to civil liability
for
engaging in any form of instruction
concerning the hysterical or current
experiences of any group protected from
discrimination
under new hampshire statute rsa 193
colon 38 and rsa 193 colon 39
i believe that students deserve an
honest education that enables them to
learn from the mistakes of the past to
create a better future for our students
our state and our country
the current law sure changes our
students from developing the tools they
need to become successful students
in developing the skills needed to
have learning experiences that will help
them succeed in higher education
pursuits and ultimately in their future
careers that is why i propose to repeal
and replace
rsa 93 colon 40.
thank you
thank you representative are there
questions from the committee
representative tanner
thank you and thank you for being here
this morning on this snowy morning and
uh thank you for presenting this bill um
my question is about um
the uh civil liberties
uh
on line six
uh it says from suggesting subjecting
them to civil
liability for
uh engaging in any form of instruction
and i'm just wondering because um i
think that
part of the
divisive concepts bill
actually worked with the department of
education to take teachers credentials
away and i was just wondering if the
civil liability
uh would matter at that point
if it's uh through the department of
education
uh the the repercussions for the person
i don't understand the question okay i'm
trying let me see if i i'm getting you
correctly um you're asking if
you're asking about specific liabilities
would that be before or after
um
a educator has been um
disciplined
right in other in other words i i think
and i'm not positive about this but i
think that
part of the penalties for teaching um
the concepts that they feel would
you know be divisive um
result in a penalty for
uh
education in the from the department of
education perhaps losing your credential
or something like that
and in here you don't mention that but
you mentioned
um
subjecting them to civil liability and
i'm just i'm not familiar with that term
i'm not
you know i'm not a lawyer so uh i don't
know
how wide of a
apron or umbrella that is in protection
and i'm that's what i'm asking oh okay
um
i'm not sure i really don't know thank
further questions representative lakis
yes i'm curious
um it says and i've been trying to
finish looking this up but at any rate
it says engaging in any form of
instruction
concerning etc
and i'm wondering what if the form of
i am not sure um
but i
would be curious to know um
who would be making the decision that
who
generally makes the decision whether
well
i think i need to rephrase that repraise
considering whether a
an action is discriminatory um
but i i don't understand in whose eyes
in the eyes of the law and the eyes of
um well according to that's what i was
trying to look up i usually do it fast
on my phone so that i would have it in
front of me but it's much slower
this way
i was trying to look up the applicable
law
so i could see exactly what the the
wording was but
when you say any form of instruction and
i think
some of the reasons some of these things
have been instituted is because the
students
or the students and parents find the
form of instruction to be discriminatory
and feel discriminated against
and would then want to be able to
ask that that not be
done and that's why i was trying to
look up the exact wording but at any
rate the object when people object it's
generally because the instruction is
discriminatory and they do feel
discriminated against
and so this any form of instruction
putting it into the discrimination in
public schools sort of undoes
that whole
chapter in
um
hang on
it's in
the uh the bill doesn't say any form of
instruction you got to read it in
context engaging in any form of
instruction concerning the historical or
current experiences of any group it
doesn't stop at any form of instruction
so i don't know where this line of
question is actually
um
could you ask a question of the
representative testifying
well i was i was wondering how if
i mean it's supposed to
that's protected from discrimination and
if the form of instruction itself is
discriminatory against
the group that is protected whoever that
is which is a huge group based on age
sex you know the the list is very long
all the things
and
and it seems to me that by saying
engaging in any form of
instruction concerning current
experiences of any group that's
protected from discrimination
by saying it that way you're almost
saying you're almost
negating the law against discrimination
because the form of instruction can be
discriminatory in and of itself and so
that's
at any rate that was
it had there was a
i'd had to ask a question yes okay i
think your question is speculative and
i'm having a really hard time giving you
an answer um
so i will um
thank you chairman cordelie
thank you again for being here this
morning and uh
taking taking my question i'm looking at
the the line that was just referenced by
representative leakes and
further uh uh
explained by representative luno
is it the intent of this line i'm
talking about six and seven
basically saying that i just wanna make
sure i'm on the same
understanding
that
teachers are going to be allowed to
teach whatever is correct
in in historical context as we now know
it
uh and they will then be
uh
will be prohibited
from being sued for teaching the
historical information as it exists is
that that's correct yes that's what this
is saying yes yeah thank you so much
thank you very much
thank you mr chair
um representative lorenzo it would
would you agree that maybe it's up to
the
administration in the school to
determine some of these kinds of things
that they're the ones that are on site
they're the ones that can walk in and
supervise the teacher they can witness
the lessons they can review the
materials
that they are the impartial people that
maybe to answer
representative lee has questions it
would wouldn't it be up to the
administration in the school to address
those issues
yes i believe so thank you
any further questions from the
committee
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
and
i do not see representative petrino
um
he indicated that he might be delayed in
another hearing but we have his a
written testimony that we can distribute
uh so uh next would be then
[Music]
sorry
good morning members of the committee
for the record my name is megan tuttle i
represent more than 17 000 new hampshire
educators as president of nea new
hampshire
for more than 168 years it's been our
mission to advocate for the children and
public school employees of new hampshire
we're committed to improving student
achievement in new hampshire public
schools providing learning opportunities
for teachers and students ensuring that
all students are ready to succeed
nda new hampshire has held from the
beginning that the current laws of
vagueness would have a chilling effect
on educators throughout the state
after seeing the law in action this year
so far our members are students we know
that this is true
after this law was passed last year nea
new hampshire made multiple requests for
specific guidance and instruction to
assist educators in staying within the
new law these requests were sent to both
the department of education and the
attorney general's office to this day
the requests have gone unanswered
new hampshire's consistently ranked as
we've heard before in the top three or
four
states with regard to public education
our students and our state lose if
opportunities to constructively address
race in our classrooms are muzzled and
criminalized by this law that's vague on
currently we have educators feeling as
they cannot allow students to dialogue
with each other to peer review each
other's work orderly let students lead
classroom discussions because they don't
know if student driven learning will
lead to a discussion that could be
interpreted as the instruction of a
banned concept
the law's broad use of the word teach
dissuades teachers from presenting
material as a jumping off point for
discussion lest they be accused of
indoctrinating students simply because
they expose them to one author's thesis
our teachers are feeling that they must
now teach material in a vacuum in order
to limit analogy students may draw to
current events that could address one or
more of the band concepts they're
hesitant to ask questions like does what
we just read or saw apply in your life
where do you see this happening now
they're concerned about opening up
discussions like that because it might
veer into banned concepts
teachers believe that students are
disadvantaged by the law because they're
not being given the opportunity to form
their own opinions or perspectives on
important social and historical issues
they're not developing analytical skills
to support any opinion that they could
form if they're not permitted to engage
in a discussion with peers or teachers
about authors failings misunderstandings
or flawed reasonings
while ignoring our request for clarity
on the new law the department of
education installed public mechanisms
for reporting educator non-compliance
and procedures to take away teaching
credentials prompting what we believe is
the first bounty ever offered on an
educator
teachers believe that false reports of
violations of the act would be extremely
damaging as they would cause unnecessary
controversy and attention up to and
including reports of the department to
the department of education
disciplinary referrals an investigation
by the school district not to mention
the harassment unwanted attention via
social media and news coverage to that
end educators are either declining to
use permissible works altogether or
removing controversial authors names
from the materials prior to presenting
them to students
the chilling effect of the band concept
act is that new hampshire educators are
now weighing meeting state standards
against losing their license in their
livelihoods
parents and teachers want to provide our
children the best education they can but
the band concept act has created an
environment that limits the context in
which kids can learn about history and
what books they can read
we should be trusting educators and
parents to ensure our kids are getting
the best education possible
teachers are trained and experienced in
education have a duty to set their
students up to be successful
contributors to society educators should
have the freedom to teach the honest
complete facts about historical events
like slavery and civil rights without
being censored and having their licenses
and livelihoods being put at risk by a
vague law
house bill 1090 restores the ability to
provide diverse educational approaches
to instruction and curriculum tailored
to meet students needs
our students deserve the freedom to
learn they deserve to be part of an
education that helps them learn from
mistakes of the past so they're better
prepared to succeed
to inhibit new hampshire's public school
educators from engaging in the kinds of
discussions that help teach and
challenge students to use this knowledge
to form their own opinion is a
disservice to them and to the state of
new hampshire on behalf of any in new
hampshire its membership i respectfully
ask you find house bill 1090 ought to
pass i do have written testimony i'll
pass in that has some more specific
examples but i didn't want to take up
much more time
thank you thank you i understand that to
the clerk
thank you um
did you receive or find the information
that the doe put out after this was done
they have a huge
um
like a brochure almost and it's on their
website that has all of those things
that you were asking for and it
specifically says that they can teach
all these things etc
i'm wondering you said you keep asking
from for guidance and they posted this
huge guidance but you said you didn't
get any help and i'm wondering have you
seen that thank you for the question yes
we sent a letter to the department of ed
in the attorney general's office once
this was first signed and we asked for
for specific books
lessons
topics etc
right after we sent that and i don't
think it was because we sent it but
right after we sent it the frequently
asked questions and guidance came out
from the attorney general's office we
did see that we then sent another one
asking for more specificity in it
because there still were not any
specific books etc that were going
against it and the law is still
extremely vague we still haven't
received answers to that so i have seen
if it's the same document that you're
speaking of
i have seen that but i think it could
have been a little more specific in
answering the questions that we asked
that were specific i can provide our
request to you if you'd like i'm more
than happy to share it i
thank you and i'm glad you saw it i
think they don't want i think they're
trying to allow flexibility
um by not
giving specifics but
that's it thank you thank you
representative moffat
thank you mr thank you for being here uh
i counted five times in your testimony
where you use the expression band
concepts can can you give us an example
or sample of a band concept um thank you
for the question i can't because there
really is no specific things the law is
so vague that there really is nothing
specific for it i could have said
divisive concepts or other words but
band concepts is just what we're using
thank you
could you tell us what specific language
in the current statute that you take
issue with
um thank you the whole statute
thank you
uh
representative uh thank you mr chair
megan thank you for being here uh
are you aware of
any situations in the state where
a teacher has
had parents a
principal
object under 193.40 for something
they've done or or proposed to do in the
classroom are you aware of any
situations like that thank you for the
question um i do have some examples in
the written testimony that are in the
lawsuit also that we filed that i'll be
turning into you so you can see those
there are specific um
i'd have to i have to go back and look
but i know that there are
educators in some of the different
counties i believe it was in
hillsborough county where they had
curriculum that was
prepared by both the educators and the
administration on certain books
i believe it was either beloved or
stamped from the beginning the kids
version of it
where everything had been approved and
then because the law was put into place
um that was stopped because of the
vagueness of it and they weren't sure if
it was going to be allowed um there is
an instance in the in the written
testimony where a parent had complained
about something and so it was stopped um
there's so there are other
examples in there for you thank you
you're welcome
for the questions uh representative
thank you chairman quinnelly
i have
two
miss most uh masato thank you so much
for being here and taking my two
questions hopefully um i'm looking at
both extremes of teaching from a
historical context
can you tell me how
our
current teaching staff i think you were
middle school if i recall correct
historically talk at one point how they
would go about teaching history if they
can't teach the entirety of history
um thank you for the question yes i
taught um eighth grade social studies us
history for 18 years
and i i think they're not teaching it
right now i think that's the problem is
because the the law is so vague it's
educators are worried that they're going
to be accused of indoctrinating or
saying something that is taken out of
context
and then the possibility of them losing
their license is on the line that's a
really very real possibility because of
the ramifications of the law so
um
i i think it's i know it's having a
chilling effect on the teaching of
history and things you know things like
critical thinking having student-led
discussions where they can ask how does
this apply to your life um things like
that are not being done and i know that
for a fact because the educators are
telling me they're not doing that
anymore okay
thank you chairman the last one um on
the far other end of the spectrum when
you get to the high school level
particularly the ap history classes and
those types of things
which typically have been very uh
socratic
and and followed up by detailed detailed
resources et cetera et cetera
those classes because the upper level
are they still going on or is it
something's halted there um thank you
for the question the the classes are
going on
um
yeah no i i do have some other examples
in here for you about ap um i'm just
trying to find it in the testimony in
the testimony i have it yeah about um ap
i apologize it's not in the
ap english at a public high school in
hillsborough county um reports that
since this law is packed they've stopped
bringing his class to life by relating
materials to current events or to
students own experiences which is a
common teaching tool educators concerned
prompting a discussion related to
current events is going to risk
misinterpretation the edu that the
educators indoctrinating students about
the viewpoints of those involved these
are examples from actual you know
educators in new hampshire are still
teaching um that are in our lawsuit as
well so these are these are happening
one more this last one guarantee
thank you
it was a while ago when i was in the
classroom but at that point in time ap
curricula was prescriptive from the ap
association
uh two parts of this one question is it
still is there still is it still
prescriptive and are we following the
prescription um thank you for the
question that is a great question i
honestly would have to check on that i'm
not sure if it's still prescriptive or
not um but i don't want to answer
incorrectly so i would i can check on
that and get back to you thank you so
much thank you chairman for your legacy
you're welcome um
i would just like to ask one question um
i think you mentioned something about
was it removing authors names before
presenting the material to the students
i didn't catch
uh what was being removed before
presenting to students
or is that maybe that's in your written
testimony thank you for the question i
think i was talking about just removing
authors
um and maybe their viewpoints from it
i'm not sure if i
i don't know if i actually said an
author's name i know they were removing
books
because the possibility of
controversy for it and i do have the
books listed in the written testimony
thank you representative porter
thank you mr chair and thank you megan
for taking my question are you aware um
of any instances where
um someone from the department of
education has contacted a teacher at
home concerning um
a complaint that they've had thanks for
the question i am aware that the
department of education has contacted
teachers directly about complaints um
yes
thank you chair cordelli thank you ms
tuttle for taking my question
um i am making the assumption that you
megan are in touch with other executive
directors of teachers unions or whatever
throughout the country
is this
divisive concepts issue uh
unique to new hampshire or is it being
discussed in other locations as well
thank you for the question um yeah i am
in touch with other state affiliate
presidents executive directors um etc
and it is um there is talk of this all
over the country i think new hampshire
from what i've seen has one of the
most vague laws
but it is being talked about
a lot of other places
thank you
um
my follow-up question
has to do with
conversations that i've had myself with
teachers who have reached out over the
past
in your discussions with people in new
hampshire or even in other locales
have you
had anybody address with you the idea of
feeling discriminated against themselves
by their situation not being allowed in
discussion
i think for the question yeah the the
feeling that i'm getting in talking to
educators and talking to other
local affiliates etc is
there's just really this feeling of
being attacked for teaching what is on
it or you know the fact that they just
want to teach honest history and be in
the classroom to teach that's what they
went to school for that's what they're
professionals at and
there's just this this it's
disheartening there's a lot of people
who are just fed up and wanting to leave
the profession at this point for a lot
of different reasons and this is part of
it
representative ellis uh thank you mr
chair um taking representative porter's
question one step further do you think
it's appropriate for
personnel or the department of education
to be contacting individual teachers
about what they're teaching in their
classroom um thank you for the question
i personally speaking i don't think it's
appropriate i think there are other ways
to go about that and i think there are
processes in place that should be
followed
to
talk to a teacher or somebody else about
complaints against them thank you
any further questions representative
lakis
yes i had the law in front of me and i
keep hearing this teachers can't teach
anything teachers can't teach anything
because they're afraid because the law
is vague and so
i'm wondering
if you can explain to me
what is vague if i go through
line by you know section by section
is it vague
one person's
characteristics because i'm not going to
basically teachers aren't supposed to
teach
that one
that one's
characteristics
are inherently superior to any others
is that vague
the thank you for the question the issue
comes in where educators are afraid to
talk about almost anything now this is
what i'm hearing from them in the
classrooms because of the fear of being
misinterpreted and if they're
misinterpreted and then everything is
investigated and it goes down the
process that's laid out their livelihood
could be done their licenses could be
taken away this is what they're telling
me we asked for specifics um from the
department of education the attorney
general's office can we teach um you
know beloved or stamps from the
beginning or there are some other
examples that are in the written
testimony and that can't be answered it
hasn't been answered the answers we're
getting are even
i'm sorry
yes do those
um
things that you're talking about
do they try to teach that one
let's say race age whatever is better
than another ace or rage i don't believe
that's what they're teaching or trying
to well then i don't understand what the
question is i'm trying to understand
what the issue is that teachers are
afraid to teach based on what i thought
was a very specific
law and you keep saying it's general
and if we're going to improve it
i'm trying to figure out
what it is that's general what it is
that's misunderstood it even says
nothing in this section
shall be construed to prohibit
discussing as part of a larger course of
academic instruction the historical
existence of ideas and subjects
identified in this section so it
specifically says they can talk about
these things it just says they can't
push them they can't advocate for them
and the things that they
express what my question is so she can
answer because i'm not understanding
what is vague
what where the breakdown is that's what
i'm trying to find where is the
breakdown between this language and what
i i don't know how else i can answer
besides what i've already said okay
thank you
agree disgrace thank you thank you
though for trying
represent tanner
thank you um would you agree that
discrimination
uh is in the eye of the beholder that um
if you're in a protected group
uh
somebody who is not in that protected
group
might say something that
uh you might feel is discriminatory
towards you and they may not so
it's do you think that this
this bill puts that if if that's true
that it's in the eye of the beholder
then
you have 25 students in your class
beholding what you're teaching
who might take offense to it is that is
that what most teachers are afraid of
thank you for the question yeah i think
you know that's it the fear is that
something is
you might not be teaching or you're not
teaching that you are inheritly you know
superior or inferior anything but the
perception of what you said is taken out
of context or taken misinterpreted and
that can lead to losing your license
yes quickly please
so
can it also be a misconception
by a student that a teacher is
inculcating or
forcing or advocating their position on
on them
thank you i think it could be yes thank
you
representative porter
thank you mr chair and thank you megan
for taking another question i'm going to
just bring you back to my teaching
career i've been out of the classroom
for a while
i taught second grade
and
when it got to be thanksgiving time it
was always
a little bit of a problem to me of how
to teach about the first thanksgiving
i knew it was a
tradition to teach it one way but i also
knew that there were
other things that might
that were not taught when i was a kid
that maybe the kids needed to know so as
i addressed that issue with them i told
them about how europeans came over
that native americans were already here
that the europeans settled on the land
that belonged to the native americans
um and that
many of the native americans afterwards
got sick and died and that um eventually
the europeans
took the land that belonged to the
native americans so that when we went
through how that would work and
i would ask the children at that time
how do you think that what do you think
about that how does that make you feel
and without the
question those second graders would say
i feel really bad for the native
americans they took away their land is
there
under this yes sir there is under the
concepts of this law
would that be
allowed do you think or would i still be
able to do that kind of teaching in
second grade now
if this law was in place
thank you so the current law in place um
what i am hearing from the educators is
they are not asking those questions
because they are
afraid
of
what is going to come out of it so in
instead of trying to
go through an entire explanation
of
both sides i guess which
is the right thing to do they're just
avoiding the topics altogether they're
just avoiding it because of what the
consequences could be to this so this
would take that completely out and
let the educators go back to teaching
thank you very much for your testimony
thank you uh next is uh jill's
i'm sorry
repton of tanner
thank you
um do you think that this bill not not
the bill we're talking about but the
repeal repeal bill
is like
perhaps having
a law for
how fast to go on the interstate highway
and the law says just be safe
and then you go what you want to on the
interstate highway and all of a sudden
you see the blue lights behind you
and they pull you over and they say you
weren't safe
would that be an analogy to how teachers
feel about teaching this in in public
schools thank you i think it could be
you know 10 build or i'm sorry 10 bill
house bill 1090 would just get rid of
what's there so it would
be a good thing in our eyes
uh representative moffatt thank you
thank you mr thank you for taking my
question
what would you do in a situation where a
classroom teacher an educator is flat
out
teaching
wrong information facts that are wrong
dates that are wrong that happens i give
you examples so my question again is
when a teacher is factually incorrect uh
what should be done
um honestly thank you for the question i
think that's really needs to go through
the school first go through
administration first before it goes
anywhere else
i think it's up to the principal to deal
with it at the first
thank you
see no further questions thank you very
much i did try to wipe but there's no
okay quickly please
my question is as i asked earlier what
if it's the school administration that
is the one that's pushing the
discriminatory
um teaching
what do you mean by pushing the
discriminatory teaching that the
administration i'm just trying to
clarify your question that the
administration
in teacher um
when they do the teacher days and
they're teaching you know telling
professional development thank you
that's the word um if it's the
administration itself that's pushing
um
discriminatory practices and asking
their teachers to teach these things
who do you go to in that case
um in my opinion you would go to either
the superintendent or the school board
at that point but that's be the people
i'm talking about if they're the ones if
the superintendent is the one who's
pushing
on the school administration these
things on the whole district say these
discriminatory teachings
i i think you answered that okay
very much
next is jill's bisnay
sorry
no
can hear me now oh wow makes a world of
difference doesn't it thank you
um
thank you mr chairman for the
opportunity to testify today my name is
jill bissonette i'm the legal director
for the aclu of new hampshire i know
that this committee has already heard
our testimony on related bills including
hb 13 13 which would extend
what we call the banned concepts act uh
to higher education so i i won't get
into as many details but of course i'm
happy to take uh questions following my
testimony our position and if it's also
okay with the committee
my testimony is really going to cover
both
um hp 1090 and 1576 i hope that that is
appropriate for the committee
to do it all together i just thought it
made sense from an efficiency
perspective
um with respect to both of these bills i
think our we support both i think our
preference uh is for the committee to
uh adopt uh hb 1090 which is a repeal
and replace of course if the committee
is is not amenable to
adopting that bill we then would prefer
the the full repeal bill which is
hb 1576
and i do want to echo some of the
testimony we heard before today we we
have very serious concerns with
um again what we're calling the the ban
concepts act um and we've in fact filed
a lawsuit along with the nea and other
stakeholders concerning that statute the
focus of that lawsuit
is on the statutes
ambiguities
which are very problematic when you
particularly when you consider the laws
penalties so i just want to get into
that just a little bit
we think that this
law is
so unclear and vague that it fails to
provide necessary guidance to educators
about what they can and cannot teach in
schools and we think that this ambiguity
very well could end up leading to
arbitrary and discriminatory enforcement
so just by way of history i know we've
all been living with this law for the
past year and a half you know as it went
through the budget cycle last year uh
but this really all does start from an
executive order that was
put in place back in september of 2020
during the right before the presidential
election
that executive order uh from president
trump actually listed out 10
banned concepts and there of course the
context was in
with respect to federal employment
federal employers as well as
federal contractors
and
some of those banned concepts in fact
were designed to include topics like um
systemic racism unconscious bias in fact
one of the interpreting memos
on top of that executive order made
clear that those were the concepts that
were designed to be at issue there was a
lawsuit over that executive order was
filed out in california
and
it was partially enjoined or partially
blocked in part on vagueness
and ambiguity grounds
and so kind of fast forward to the new
hampshire kind of iteration of of this
law when it was placed in the budget
it
has four of those concepts that were in
president trump's executive order
so
in in our view those four concepts have
the same vagueness same ambiguity
problems that president trump's
executive order had
so there's a couple kind of highlights
behind
this statute on top of its ambiguities
with respect to the four concepts
on top of that are really serious
penalties right so um just to outline
you know the the act imposes penalties
for violating its provisions one remedy
for example
for a perceived violation is a civil
action in superior court against the
government entity probably a school
district maybe even the teacher for
damages and equitable relief including
an injunction to stop training or
instructing on that bank concept i think
perhaps the penalty that's garnered the
most attention i think reasonably so
is how a violation of this statute is
construed to be a violation of the
educator's code of conduct which is put
in place several a few years ago i think
around 2018
2019 and one of the penalties for under
the educator's code of conduct is is the
equivalent of really the death penalty
for teacher right the complete loss
of licensure um so i think at its core
the concern that we have is you have
ambiguities with respect to what's
prohibited
plus very serious penalties for
violations and the result of that kind
of recipe is a chill is teachers being
so fearful
of those penalties that they won't get
they don't want to they're so worried
about their covering these topics
they're just not going to cover these
topics and i think we've now with the
lived experience of this law having been
in place for four or five months now we
are starting to see that um and this is
kind of pivoting now to my my second
point um is
that there have been efforts to get
concrete guidance from the department of
education
not just you know uh
at a high level but at a very concrete
level you know there have been requests
made for example
is tiffany jewell's book this book is
anti-racist banned under the act is the
book stamped for kids banned under the
act and this the state just won't answer
those basic questions and that is
concerning to me
the department of education is one of
the enforcers of this statute so i think
they have an obligation to explain with
clarity not just at a high level but a
discrete granular level
what is covered and what isn't because
if a teacher guesses wrong
they can be hauled into court but
perhaps even more seriously they could
lose their teacher's license so
that is something that i'm very
concerned about it's just a complete
inability in the context of discrete
concrete examples to get guidance
because if this law was so simple and
easy to understand it was so clear
the department of education would have
easy answers to these questions right
yes this is covered or no this isn't
covered
these discussions on race and gender
that are being chilled
under this law are really i think
absolutely critical
um the failure or the inability to cover
these
topics
is harmful because the actual discussion
of these topics it provides benefits for
students i think and and as well as for
society at large student body body
diversity
and the results in diversity and views
and perspectives and improves critical
thinking and problem solving it
increases cross-racial understanding
reduces stereotypes and prejudices and
develops leadership and critical
thinking skills so there are harms when
these discussions and these instructions
are chilled
and i think relatedly we are seeing a
rapid diversification of the state of
new hampshire we've seen this with
respect to the 2020 census and where is
new hampshire's growing diversity it is
actually in young people and so i think
for those reasons it is all the more
important that we have these discussions
in the classroom because instruction on
race and gender including on concepts
that address diversity diversity equity
inclusion they not only serve to close
existing opportunity gaps but they help
create a greater sense of belonging
among those communities so with that
i'll close my testimony and again just
to reiterate i think our hope is that
the committee would adopt and pass 1090
and if the committee is not inclined to
do so that it would adopt the repeal
bill which is
hp 1576. thank you
thank you
uh questions from the committee
representative moffat
thank you again mr chair and thanks for
taking my question thank you so i'm
most of us have been in the classroom
and
have
are imagining us being in the classroom
now with uh this
this uh this new statue
so it occurs to me that if there is a
complaint or a concern
um unless there is a
video or an audio of the class it really
devolve or descends to like a he said
she said scenario so i'm just my
question is uh in terms of a complaint i
don't know if there have been any
complaints yet uh there may i don't know
but if or when there is ever a complaint
about some sort of uh teacher behavior
um
does does the aclu have a position on
classroom recordings i know
during covert there's been a lot of
hybrid and remote learning but do you
have a position on
classroom recordings
thinking that it might protect a teacher
i'm not sure if we have taken a position
on that i think you know there
uh probably is a debate or growing
debate as to what extent there are
expectations of privacy in the classroom
because it's not a typical kind of
public place necessarily i don't know i
don't i don't think our organization has
necessarily taken a position on that
um but it's a good question
yeah can i just follow up on that that
actually is why because you're right
with respect to course room and
instruction there's kind of a natural
filter you know students will come home
and bring home you know either a comment
that another student made or what a
teacher said and you know there's just
natural filtering that happens you know
you don't necessarily get the picture
you're right without something more
definitive that to me is actually why
it's all the more critical in the
context of books right we know that a a
teacher is or students are reading a
book cover to cover we know exactly what
that book says right because it's
published that to me is why it's all the
more important in the context of books
right to have a greater understanding as
this is covered and is this not covered
and that just guidance at least in my
view hasn't been provided
thank you very much
uh reference tanner
uh thank you and thank you for taking my
question
i want to go back to a question that i
asked before um and the person really
didn't um
you know know for sure but in um 1090
there's a line that says um
that
that uh barring any person employed by a
public school district school
administrative unit or public academy
from
from or
subjecting them to civil liability for
engaging in any form of cons of
instruction blah blah you know
historical concept does that civil
liability subjecting them to civil
liability the prohibition to that does
that
uh also apply to the department of
education taking away their teaching
credential
not necessarily it is that that's a
separate procedure that i think exists
out outside
the court system
this is at least in 1090s context this
is a repeal and replace so the
certification issue that i talked about
would be repealed
the language i think in 1090 is designed
frankly to honestly create
greater flexibility just to make
abundantly clear that when these
discussions are are occurring to give
breathing space for those discussions
that there isn't also then the
possibility of being hauled into court
which is a a component of the banned
comp system act right it's not just the
teacher certification
ramification there's also separate
provisions in the statute that make
clear as i noted in the outset of my
testimony that
you could be hauled into court there
could be requests for damages and
junctive relief etc so i think that
language in 1090 is designed probably to
get more at that that piece does that
make sense thank you
follow up
um
my other question is also on terminology
often in these laws we see uh the
terminology free freedom from
discrimination
um and i was and then
we have other ones that are
uh you know relative to certain
discrimination i was wondering if you
could in your mind
discern what's the difference between
being free from discrimination
and um
and discrimination itself
i think that's a great question i'm not
i think i have to give some thought to
it i think one of the things that
has kind of become clear to me in kind
of reviewing the statute learning a
little bit more about it talking to
teachers in particular and talking to
impacted communities
is when you look at that term kind of
discrimination in a vacuum and
particularly how it's defined in this
statute through these these four kind of
concepts that i that i would assume are
attempting to define
in permissible discrimination
is that
it is so difficult to define that it is
almost impossible not to
at least arguably ban
instructions concerning lived
experiences that have a connection to
historical events
instructions around that asking
questions like you know how does the
legacy of slavery impact folks today
that is really though it's really
difficult to answer and because of those
ambiguities i just think that's why
you're seeing the chill that's of course
why i think as well
a california district judge
you know preliminarily enjoined
see no further questions thank you oh
i'm sorry representative mullen thank
you mr chair i'm i'm always behind
something over here uh thank you for
taking my question
so um one of the current concerns that i
have had with the uh prohibition on
teaching discrimination is that a lot of
it depends upon personal perception
and
so i'm going to ask you uh the same
question mr bisnet that i put somewhat
forward towards
uh megan tuttle
and that is let's say i'm a member of
the black community the
disability community the gay community
and i
feel that things are not being taught
about
my experience
is there the potential for families to
claim that that in and of itself is
discrimination that if
history is being denied
is that in fact a form of discrimination
against the protected classes
yeah i mean i think one of the things
that we're we're seeing the books that
are being pulled or you know are being
kind of shelved
who's writing those books they're people
of color right right talking about their
experiences and trying to write about
those experiences in a way that relates
to students
and so
taking those books away i think is
deeply harmful belittling to those uh
lived experiences and so i mean it is
something that we are concerned about is
that chill and how it has an impact on
those affected communities
follow up thank you
is it unreasonable for me to think that
if uh we've got
school district a
and
books are being removed and they
as you said the authors happen to be
from a divergent
would it
is is it feasible to think that legal
action could be taken and a case could
be made for
the fact that the authors of the books
that are being uh questioned are among
minority groups
it's a good question i have to give some
thought thought to it um
it's a good question i i as as a lawyer
i try not to opine in areas that i
haven't fully researched
um but i uh
i see the validity of that concern
absolutely thank you representative
porter
thank you mr chair thank you it's good
to see you again good to see you yes um
you're blocked by a speaker yeah i am
i'm always blocked they do that on
purpose
is the unconscious bias
part of what a concept that is banned in
new hampshire i have two parts to this
question
yeah is that one of the
concepts that we think is being it's
potentially banned no doubt can i i
can't wait to flush that out a little
bit why or yeah okay so
what i have in front of me is is a study
that was
an article from bloomberg equality that
was published in july 29 2021
and the title is job applicants with
black names in quotes still less likely
to get interviews
this is a study that's been going on for
years where they submit
identical uh
resumes with different names to
businesses and
most likely the people
with the black names don't get called as
often back as the
people who don't have the black names
if a teacher was to teach or present
this to their class in
social sciences
in a new hampshire high school
could they be called
out as part of this um
thank you very much mr chair and thank
you uh uh very very much deals for for
um joining us uh again this morning um
looking at where's oh thank you
i couldn't see where you were i'm sorry
with the masks and that's all right now
thank you thank you mr chair
no so um
so referring back to the the current law
in 195.40
um
and uh the language
that talks about no pupil in any public
school and then it goes on to towards
the end of the statute into the
violations
and
what takes place there but does the
current language in your
estimation discriminate against licensed
teachers in school districts when
compared with other licensed teachers
who practice
in other
public school settings or in non-public
schools that are under contract
with a school district or maybe student
maybe teachers licensed
teachers
who practice as part of the um the
education freedom account program
so this this only covers
uh the the portions that you're dealing
with that you're referencing i believe
dealing with the educators code of
conduct and the license ramifications
there only deal with teachers who are
certified um uh
uh
by by the state so i'm actually less
concerned with kind of private schools
i'm assuming that you can teach at a
private school without certainly i don't
i don't i don't know the answer to that
yeah
i didn't ask about private schools
okay sorry but the um but the bill
the bill the current law the bill
obviously repeals
193.40 so i think this is this is a
relevant uh question to the bill because
because it's specific to current law
but
current law
in in
193 440
roman 4
says violation of the section by an
educator shall be considered a violation
of the educator code of contact the
code of conduct that justifies
disciplinary sanction by the state board
of education then roman five goes on to
say for the purpose of this section
educator means a professional employee
of any school district whose position
requires certification by the state
board so so my question goes
it really pertains to discrimination
against educators who are employed
by any school district as opposed to
educators again professionals who are
certified by the state board of
education licensed by the state board of
education
as a teacher who who may teach in a in
another public school setting and
examples of this
would be would be
who teach in a chartered public school
or who teach in a non-public school that
is under contract with a school district
or
teach as part of the education freedom
account program
as we know that that there are sections
in the in the education freedom account
program specifically under
may
you know
may need to become involved in terms of
reviewing a student's an efa student's
portfolio so so this section to me seems
to only call out educators
who are licensed
i'm sorry
educators who are employed by a public
school district and not those who are
employed
in other public school settings and and
my question is is that discriminatory
against against teachers who
are employed by public school by school
districts it's certainly a distinction
the law is making i see the point i see
the point you're raising okay thank you
representative
thank you chairman quickly please
thank you chairman ellie
uh yeah thank you so much for taking my
question i appreciate you being here um
i had three questions but i'm not going
to ask them because i know
billy's trying to save time but i won't
follow up on one sure i was thinking of
the comments that representatives to my
right here made about
uh discrimination i mean look kept on
looking back at your thing on censorship
your statement of 5-3
is the um if this
law is now construed requires educators
to omit
information that typically they may
would have presented in a classroom
is the omission of information being
presented discrimination in itself by
again that's a good question
discrimination in the legal sense you
know i i think i just want to give more
thought to it i mean i can tell you that
as a policy matter
that is
the nub of our concern right with this
statute is that ambiguities plus
strict penalties create that very
environment where certain instruction is
not occurring instruction that we that
is beneficial uh and we think critical
frankly as new hampshire becomes more
nervous i'm not trying to evade your
question i just from a from a legal
perspective i i don't know if i've quite
thought that through
thank you thank you chairman
uh thank you very much for your time
thank you mr chairman
uh next
thank you committee chair thank you
company members i want to talk to you a
little bit about a story from a long
long time ago
um my um
child went to school one day came back
and i said how was school she said
didn't like it
i said oh my goodness first grader well
it was pre preschool it was head start
so this is how long i go back um i said
she said didn't like it i said why not
don't want to talk about it
and she was very passionate about
i'm not going there um
so throughout the entire night i
continued to try to talk to her about
what happened in school
finally she disclosed scary man came
scary man came talked about scary stuff
showed me
took me to a scary place showed me scary
things
this was at the same time
that there was um a public
uh preschool in massachusetts that was
being brought up on sexual allocations
so as a parent you can understand my
concern
i immediately went to the school and
tried to figure out who scary man was
and what the heck what they were doing
in my child's school
it took about a week and a half
to determine that scary man was officer
friendly
officer friendly was a scary man because
i had not done a good job with my child
to identify that police officers with
had i just jumped
and filed a complaint
that daycare and those teachers would
have gone through a huge fiasco huge
investigation
the bottom line is is that
we as a society have taken sides we we
talk about diversity well diversity is
actually a negative concept if you look
at diverse
diverse is division
diverse the the definition of diverse is
different from one another on the
unalike
composed of distinct or unlike elements
or qualities
when did we start when did we start
identifying people by the negative
our educators have a fantastic
opportunity
to make our uniqueness
wonderful
when did our uniqueness become a
negative thing
when when when my children were young
and they came home and one of the kids
in the class wore the little thing on
their head they asked what was that all
about because they'd never seen it
before i as a parent was able to educate
them when did we take
the ability from our educators to
provide children with both sides
without putting in their own opinions
and let children
work collaboratively with the parents
and the teachers because i can honestly
i honestly believe most of our educators
would welcome
and i've heard it time and time again
parents parents use us as babysitters
well if you don't want to be used as
babysitters engage with the parents
start becoming involved start start
having conversations i know they're hard
our society has become a society of
keyboard warriors we don't we don't talk
about the difficult conversations
anymore and that's why
this bill for me is a problem
the only reason why this bill for me is
a problem is because it further divides
the teachers and the pa our educators
and our parents
it furthers pins one against the other
and that's not okay the bottom line is
discrimination is discrimination but
it's also i believe in the eye of the
beholder so just because officer
friendly was scary to my daughter
doesn't mean it's scary to everybody
just because being a black or brown
child in our world today
should not
we shouldn't focus on their differences
when did we start focuses on differences
let's start focus on what we are similar
humanity
our educators should not be forced to
teach children about our differences
they should be taught they should be be
allowed
to educate on our similarities they
should be allowed to provide education
on all sides
and and then help the children like
representative porter
had explained help them she presented
both sides she presented the whole piece
and then help children to learn critical
thinking skills and if i look up what is
a critical thinking skill that's also
ethics and morals
i don't think our educators want to
force our children into developing
ethics and morals they want to
collaborate with the parents because
that student is theirs for six hours a
day
but they're also the parents children
i mean
the bottom line is we need a
collaborative cooperative
um atmosphere and laws like this and
even the law unfortunately the law that
was put in place last year
the only reason why i have a problem
with that law is because i felt like it
had to be in place to protect
our good educators and to try and focus
on the educators that are not educating
but potentially in doctoring
thank you and i'm more than welcome to
take any questions
thank you very much are there any
questions from the committee
seeing none thank you thank you
uh the next person uh we have here is
you're okay thank you very much
that's appreciated
by all
asthma
ashma
i've already said good morning in the
elevator
good
good morning
take this off
just so that you can clearly hear me
uh good morning committee my name is
asma huni and i am here to testify on
two bills
hb 1090 and also if you allow me hb 1576
because they're just so similar
so again my name is asan alhini and i do
not have my lobby badge but i am a
lobbyist with rights on democracy but i
am also here in my capacity as a proud
immigrant a person of color and a muslim
all these identities give me a unique
experience in this country
after 9 11 my whole community was
painted with the same brush
one of suspicion distrust and to be
watched even though the majority of
muslims had no connection to the
terrorists who committed violence
who committed the violence we were all
painted with the same brush
unlike other terrorists like the
oklahoma city bombing where a white man
committed violence not all white people
our community had to register on lists
we were still we are and were
surveillanced we were put on something
called no-fly lists we have laws created
in ordinances to justify to make sure
that we don't put mosques or places of
worship in town
we're pulled aside in airports we can be
arrested and never told why
because if you use the excuse terrorists
then you don't have to tell muslims why
they're being arrested and so there's no
due process
this is called institutional racism
when i get pulled aside at the airport
90 percent of the time when i fly it is
called institutional racism
you see to me it's not a question of
whether institutional racism exists
it exists in our country it exists in
our state i live it my community lives
it the question is are we brave enough
to be willing to address this and to
talk about it to make sure it changes
i want to be honest with you and share
that public schools have not been a safe
place for me and for people that look
like me
i
when i was a child i had not only
students mock me but also teachers
no young person deserves this every
child deserves to learn the truth about
our nation our state our communities but
the truth is new hampshire is not immune
if you look at the new hampshire fiscal
policy institute you will learn the many
different ways racism still exists today
if you truly believe that racism does
not exist anymore you are the reason why
we must have these honest discussions
that can only be had when bills like
this are in this bill is in place not
last session's bill because last
session's bill makes these conversations
impossible and you're hearing from
teachers that want to teach truth that
they are not doing so
so i'm asking today to do the right
thing and repeal last year's bill by
and just the other thing we've heard
already there are two lawsuits in new
hampshire around this bill we know that
we are making our great teachers want to
leave this state and we're keeping
awesome teachers who want to come in
from coming to new hampshire because of
these laws so if you have any questions
i'll be more than happy to answer them
thank you very much are there any
questions from the committee
not seeing hands thank you very much
okay and just like just wanted to point
out just um because there was something
said about like well what if communities
like mine want to actually um
to say something like you know there's
books that are um being discriminating
against my community which has happened
um in florida the council on american
islamic relations took that on um there
is processes currently in place for my
community to go through so i think it
really belongs to local instead of the
state addressing that and so um yeah so
just the school board the superintendent
and then there's other avenues if we
don't get um you know if that doesn't
get solved that way so please do repeal
this it's we can't we can't be living in
a state like this it's just harming us
right so thank you very much we do we
did we just received another card here
thank you chair and members of the
committee my name is maria perez i'm a
state representative for district 23
hillsborough milford new hampshire
i'm here in support of this bill
it's an immigrant
someone who i was born in el salvador i
moved here when i was 15 years old
i didn't know the language i didn't know
the culture i didn't know the history
and i really really appreciate
everything that i learned
going to the adult learning center
i went where i got my ged i learned
history
i learned the background a lot of people
we have so much so much diversity we
have so many different cultures we have
so many different languages
that i really really think
that we need to keep that it's an
immigrant it is critical for me to learn
the history
the history not just me but the history
of many of many of us that we hear
in order to respect
everyone's differences i i believe that
is is
it's a good way for teachers like my
kids that were born here but they've
really appreciated like my daughter and
she worked for
our corporate office
she appreciate the background that she
she has the latino background but she
appreciated everything that she learned
from other cultures because that helping
her in her position to be able to
understand
how other cultures are different and how
can she manage and not
feel uncomfortable when um different
religions and different cultures being
brought up to her working environment so
for that reason i will ask this
committee to support this bill
thank you very much representative are
there questions from the committee
not seeing any thank you very much thank
you
with that i have no more pink cards on
yeah
for committee members i know you've been
sitting here for a long time if you have
to take a short break
is there anybody that needs to get up
and you know where everybody's good
okay
okay with that i'm going to go ahead and
1576 is repealing the law relative to
certain uh discrimination in public
workplaces and education i would ask
that if folks are going to just repeat
what they said in 1090 please don't go
all the way through that dissertation
again
uh just try to stay on this bill and if
you have testified earlier today uh you
might echo those remarks but please
don't you know go into you know saying
the same thing over and over uh that
will help everybody here so with that
i'd like to
welcome uh representative spacia if you
have uh
a pink card give that to us at the it's
coming around the table okay thank you
and i'll have uh written testimony for
your clerk so that'd be great thank you
and for those that have written
testimony please would you just go
through it and summarize it for us hit
on the main points uh
that way if it's written testimony we
will get copies of that thank
you thank you mr chair and i just i want
to say i know that this is the third
bill on the this issue so i'm going to
try to just
stick to the points here um but i come
to offer hb 1576
to what is known as a repeal to the
divisive concepts language
and to give context in 2021 a ban on
divisive concepts was voted in and ended
up being tabled
but like so much legislation in the past
it came through came back in hb2 of the
budget and as we know the budget and the
trailer passed last year and was signed
by the governor
um i spoke to colleagues who believe
that while they supported a majority of
the budget this and other pieces of hb2
were things they were not happy with but
believe this budget needed to pass so
i and other colleagues are here are uh
to repeal this provision of the budget
and i'll start with what this bill
denies our students from learning it
denies our students from learning the
actual history of our country
and for example they won't learn that
staves or slaves were actually
owned here in new hampshire past the
revolutionary war and learned that
heroes like frederick douglass denounced
the practice of building statues of
confederate soldiers known as the lost
cause
is the history of the trail of tears
uncomfortable of course it is but i
heard that if we cannot if we do not
learn about our history we are doomed to
repeat it
this means teaching our younger
generation of the struggle that so many
faced in the past and that we don't
sugarcoat it
this is not meant to cast the blame on
the sins of our forefathers or on us
today
this is meant to see the effects of how
discrimination in the past is still
present in our current system still
we still see discrepancies in
generational wealth between racial and
ethnic groups we still see that parts of
our countries
and parts of our country you can still
you can be hired one day and fired
another because of your gender
orientation
we even know that by prohibiting the
conversation of history of the
disability community we are preventing
ourselves from learning how recent the
ada has been around in our country which
is
fairly recent um you can even tell
how recent desegregation has happened
and that you know segregation is still a
structural issue that exists in our
country
we have made strides for progress to so
many vulnerable groups the establishment
of this ban has made it incredibly
difficult for our educators to do their
job
we have seen a website created to report
any educator in our state from doing
their job at a time during a global
pandemic when their jobs are hard enough
just to keep our kids healthy and safe
it's bad enough our educators spend
money out of their pockets so that they
can provide a great experience in the
classrooms or that their res that the
resources that your classroom receives
relies entirely on the zip code that you
live in
we are we're doing it a service to our
educators our public employees and our
citizens by gagging their speech and
trying to erase our history so i urge
this committee to vote to pass on hb
1576 to repeal this dangerous provision
from law and i'll answer any questions
thank you very much are there questions
from the committee
represented woodcock
president good morning thank you for
coming just for clarity purpose of those
uh reading through the bill again and
uh can you explain to me the our
simplified layman terms
uh the
the rsa 354
how it connects to uh our current rsa
19340 in education
yeah so i mean this thank you this is
this is inserted from um from our
previous budget and um this is something
that we you know like i said many of our
like would be put into our education
statute from from the trailer bill um
it really makes it much more vague to
understand what discrimination you know
looks like in our in our for education
so it makes it tougher for our educators
to go from there so i
you know i think
this is we want to make sure that we you
know we aren't making it difficult for
educators to be able to teach this
thank you thank you chairman further
questions represent tanner
thank you mr chair
thank you
for taking my question
people keep looking around i was
wondering i asked this before and i i
still haven't gotten a really good
answer on it but
um can you
define for me what you think the right
to freedom from discrimination means
it's a good question
um i mean in theory it would be the idea
that you
wouldn't feel that
i mean i'll take it from myself if i
felt that the right discrimination
wouldn't feel like i would be pre-judged
because of the color of my skin so to
speak that i wouldn't you know i would
feel comfortable in most spaces because
of who i am
um but structurally i know that's not
real i know that doesn't exist
it's you know i love i would love to
live in a world that is colorblind that
world just doesn't exist um it is it is
unfortunate um because
there are
people people are gonna read my resume
and they're going to see manuel espitia
and they're going to say manuel manuel
manuel he must be from a foreign country
they will have these preconceived
judgments already and that's not like
you know it's not to cast blame on folks
it's it's just
like i struggle with it sometimes too i
i will have these these biases that have
i've grown up with
um
but unfortunately that's just it's it's
it's hard to rewire our brains to kind
of think otherwise
and this is not to say that people are
you know inherently born a certain way
this is just you know we are we are we
are shaped by our environment we are
shaped by the places that we live and it
unfortunately makes it so some
some people may have a
worse off experience than others so
i would i would wish that it would be a
you know living free of discrimination
would be a way where people would be
treated equally
but i unfortunately don't think that
we're we're there just yet thank you
thank you mr chairman um
represent investment
espionage
i do know that i know
i just can't talk this morning um one of
the prior wetnesses and i think it was
jill's bassinet testified that
he would rather see
house bill 1190 the bill immediately we
heard immediately before this passed
then your bill passed um which was a
repeal and replace and yours is simply a
repeal and he said but if that didn't
pass you'd like your bill it's a second
choice but i'm wondering how you feel
about
house bill 1090 as an alternative to
i mean i think house bill 1090 is i
think a great approach i think um you
know we we here in the house see many
bills and there's not you know it's not
one way to skin a cat so to speak which
is
um there's more than you know there are
multiple ways to handle you know an
issue
um and i think if if hp 1090 passed i
think i would i would also be happy um
so i would um but i i definitely think
we're we're trying to address the
central problem that uh that was created
by by hb2 so um i would be i would be
happy with with the passage of hb 1090.
thank you further questions
yes representative mullen
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my questions
so i'm looking at the
finance note that came with uh your bill
and i'm
particularly looking at
rsa 354 a 29
which is described as providing
restrictions on certain educational
programs
by public employers
and allows any person aggrieved by an
act
to seek a remedy under a whole bunch of
different subsections you know what i'm
referring to in that financial note yes
so i i i'm
correct am i correct
that
that portion of your bill would
primarily uh apply to
adults
and what we're talking about is adults
being offended aggrieved
however you want to uh phrase it right
over something that an employer feels
they want to offer some sort of
professional development in
am i correct in that yes
could you uh follow up mr chair could
you give me a couple of examples of
something that an employer might want to
offer professional development on
i mean i actually funny enough later
today i have a cultural competency
uh i can't i have a cultural competition
competency training later on um which i
think is great if you want to learn more
about how to be culturally competent and
learn how to you know address you know
certain different groups so some people
might get offended by that and say why
would i need to do this so um but i
think that might be an example of that
thank you
i'm seeing a lot of myself here so let's
we have uh
other than self we have two three cards
which have organizations like aft or new
futures or aclu
we will be hearing from so if you have a
tactical just
hanging off no disrespect
okay
so with that
uh
sorry good morning my name is jama
wilder and i am from hollis new
hampshire i'm here representing myself
i have spoken before the board before
but as you know i have five children
and two of them are in the public school
education i started researching what crt
was and to better understand it and what
divisive concepts were
crt is basically creating a utopian
society that is never attainable
they are putting an oppressor versus an
oppressed
and they are placing guilt on a
generation that had nothing to do with
it
i have taught my children to judge
someone on their character and not on
their race color creed or religion
since they have come home in the last
year they have told me that they have
never
noticed color more than they have since
they started going through these classes
they are teaching them to see color of a
person's skin instead instead of showing
them the kindness and love that they
should be teaching i'm going to read an
example of one of the assignments that
was given in our school
they had two sources that they could go
to and they followed up with questions
it says after reading information on
both links list some examples of
systemic racism in the u.s
according to the article from the
booking institute explain how we have
racism in the us today without racist
how do you think the media and pop
culture contribute to creating negative
images of people of color
men black men in particular
it goes on to
list a quote which
i don't know about you but i found this
disturbing considering it happened in
1968 and they're trying to make
comparisons of what happened then to our
society today
what are your thoughts on the following
quote from john edward
i'm sorry a richmond
one of the former president richard
nixon's aides
the nixon campaign in 1968 in the nixon
white house after that had two enemies
the anti-war left and black people you
understand what i'm saying we knew we
couldn't make it illegal to be either
against the war on black but by getting
the public to associate hippies with
marijuana and blacks with heroin then
criminalizing both heavily we could
disrupt those communities we could
arrest their leaders raid their homes
break up their meetings and vilify them
night after night on the evening news
we did know we were lying about the
drugs of course we did this is in 1968
they're using a quote to try to make
children have feelings about what's
going on in our society today
it's followed up by saying many
politicians including the clintons newt
gingrich and charles rangel in this film
have apologized for their role in
promoting devastating tough on crime
legislation
considering the billions of dollars made
off the imprisonment of people and the
ongoing practice of prison labor and the
cases of unjust imprisonment as we see
in the tragic case of caliph broder is
an apology enough
should our country be compelled to repay
these communities and families in a more
material restorative way why or why not
they also have questions like this
settling into agriculture societies was
the biggest mistake made in human
history agree or disagree
civilization always leads to an
inequality between its people
all of the inequality of the world can
be traced back to geological luck
i wanted you to see how these questions
were formed so you understood that it's
not an
issue of
being able to teach about the past
the problem is when teachers are
presenting material in a way
that is not accurate to what's going on
in our society
we've heard testimony about racism and
people being considered terrorists based
on race which is completely wrong
i have been seen by some as a domestic
terrorist because i'm a mother fighting
for my children's well-being racism will
never go away it is all throughout the
world our educators should not be
dividing our children and making them
feel guilty for the sins of their
forefathers
i believe
in teaching history
and teaching it from different
perspectives but i do not believe that
is the job of an educator to tell my
children how to believe
and to divide our nation there is enough
divisiveness and division going on in
our society
by asking teachers not to teach about
racism
it stops them from giving them
thank you thank you very much are there
any questions from the committee yes
representative woodcock
thank you chairman um thank you for
taking my questions and
i appreciate you being back here again
today uh the questions uh that were
presented by the faculty member to your
youngsters for the agree disagree like a
dislike that you read
uh from history and from the
administration nixon those types of
things
can you tell me what grade level that
was
that was um sophomore and junior classes
but one of the biggest concerns that i
have about what they're doing is that
they're allowing them only to go to one
or two sources at one point in the year
my daughter um wanted to go to another
source and she used a direct quote from
from someone's writings and then
gave her analogy or her thoughts on it
and the teacher came back and said that
she thought that it was argumentative
and that she needed to redo the
assignment
and so
they're not allowing them any critical
thinking they're saying you can go to
one source
and if you step outside of that source
then you are not then you need to redo
your assignment
thank you thank you
thank you further questions
yes representative ellison thank you mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question i just want to be clear that
that that i that i think i heard you
correctly so maybe you can clarify this
for me okay did you just say that racism
should not be
a topic that should be discussed in
public school or school classrooms i
think that they should be teaching
how racism looks because what they're
doing is in the divisive concepts
they're not presenting the facts they're
going back and they're and you i'm sure
you heard what i read for the questions
correct with the they gave them two
sources to go to and then they followed
up and the whole
point and this is this is one example
you know i was trying to show you kind
of what is going on in the classroom is
that the teachers are coming in whether
it's israel and palestine or whatever
the conflict is they're presenting it in
a way that says one of them was an
oppressor and one of them was oppressed
and several times my children have come
home from school in
many conflicts throughout history and
said this was the good one this was the
bad one
and
they're doing it in a 45-minute video
with some follow-up questions
and my concern is they shouldn't be
presenting information in a way that
doesn't allow them to understand all the
facts and do critical thinking and
understand what really happened in
history
thank you thank you
bowman thank you mr chair and thank you
jama for coming in again
do you can you tell me
what
nationality
in the world pretty much has not been
discriminated against talking about
germans irish italians
i don't believe that there's any and
that's why i said it's worldwide the
problem is is that a lot of these
teachers are saying it's only happening
in america and they're not giving an
accurate representation of what's
happening all over the world
they said something like
you know all americans are living on
stolen land one of the teachers did and
i said all across the world everyone's
living on stolen land
but they're not presenting it that way
and it's not right
thank you
perfect
thanks very much mr chair thanks for
joining us this morning um you had
mentioned the the two sources that um
that that your uh your daughter's um
teacher had had asked them to to use one
of them i think you mentioned was
brookings institution i was wondering if
you could tell us what the other one was
business insider was the other one
and it was it was called
dot www.allsides.com
uh front slash news
dash source front slash business uh
slash insider thanks and follow up how
would you characterize these two um
um
sources primary sources or so i i have
not done much information into or i
haven't done a lot of research into
those specifically i um the
biography.com
was another source that my daughter was
told was the only one she could go to
and
it was um i found it to be very generic
i found only certain dates and only
certain resources or papers listed that
they wrote so it's not giving it's
basically putting people in a box and
saying this is what we want to share
about them
for instance she was studying john dewer
and he was the first president of the
teachers union and he had studied in
china and the soviet union
about communism and she
did more research into it and said this
is where he had done his education these
are the papers that he wrote and that's
when she was stopped by that specific
teacher saying
you're not allowed to share that
information because it doesn't go along
with the assignment that we're trying to
present
so any free thinking outside of that i'm
not i can't
you know specifically speak to those two
but i think it's wrong that they're not
having children go and do their own
research and if there's credible sources
or you know or non-credible sources they
should have debates about it and they
should find ways to have them do more
research because there are good and bad
um
sources out there
but
further questions from the committee
narcina thank you very much thank you uh
jonathan weinberg are you on are you
going like this again
i wanted to make sure we got to this
hearing in time while you're here
um my name is jonathan weinberg i'm a
member of the concord school board uh
but while i'm here in my capacity as an
individual i'm not speaking on behalf of
the board
i see how house bill 1576 is critical
legislation for many aspects but firstly
to combat the fear and teachers that
they will be reported for merely
teaching history
as we all surely know the group mobs for
liberty placed a bounty on teachers
heads if they were found guilty of
teaching so-called divisive concepts
if this wasn't enough to make educators
weary concurrently the state of new
hampshire instituted a snitch system
where parents and individuals could
report educators who violated the
recently passed divisive concepts
legislation
yet outside of the legislative chambers
it appears no one can really define what
divisive concepts are
last summer as a member of the city and
community relations committee on the
concord school board i represented the
board with fellow members at a booth
every saturday by the state house
this created a unique opportunity to
engage with constituents and community
members outside of a formal meeting
setting
as expected we received many questions
about back to school
but the most common questions were about
if we taught crt or critical race theory
or even what the so-called new divisive
concepts are
one of the main questions i inquired of
those asking was what do they define as
critical race theory then individuals
would typically say
that is when you make white people hate
themselves
and what was even more staggering was
when someone said to me
it is basically a new version of slavery
i was taken aback by this claim that
critical race theory was slave slavery
reincarnated
i want to recommend the book the new jim
crow by michelle alexander
as that provides another view on what a
new iteration of slavery is
yet that would unfortunately most likely
fall under the forbidden books list
other times people make comments
equating critical race theory to nazi
propaganda
as not only an individual in education
but especially as a jewish person to
hear these comments comparing the
teaching of history to a time when my
great-grandfather was in a concentration
camp is despicable
we live in a state where critical race
theory has become an umbrella term for
everything it is not
a misnomer
and what is even more tragic is how the
state of new hampshire and state
legislature have only fanned the flames
of misinformation as they legitimized
the misidentification of critical race
theory as either not to propaganda or
encouraging people to suggest that it is
a new age of slavery this must stop i
urge you to pass house bill 1576. thank
you
thank you very much uh do you have
written testimony there that yes
so could we have a copy of it please for
the record any any questions
not cnn thank you very much
next
card i have here is jonathan
thank you mr chairman and honored
representatives thank you for this uh
your service and this opportunity to
address you i'm rabbi jonathan spira
savette
i live and work in nashua where i'm the
father of three children who are
students and graduates of our nashua
public schools
i myself have been a high school teacher
of american history and literature and i
currently serve on our state's
commission for holocaust and genocide
education
i come to you to speak in strong support
of this bill
this country saved the life of my family
and my wife's family from the tyranny of
the tsar and the genocide of hitler i am
a proud american and a religious person
who says a religious blessing over
freedom whenever i vote and in the
voting booth and when i come to the
state house are here like today i wear
those commitments on my body and above
my head
i feel that my own group's history
obligates me in gratitude to be a civic
leader in this country and i carry
responsibilities
as a member of both a religious minority
and the white majority
earlier in my career i had the
opportunity to create from scratch a
course for high school juniors about
america in place of the typical us
ap history and literature curriculum
i was working at a private jewish high
school and together with a colleague we
set out to give our students
interdisciplinary tools
to look at american history and culture
and to look at themselves as critical
citizens connected critics to use the
terminology of the political philosopher
michael waltzer
perhaps this was natural for us as jews
a group who have so often
lived the american dream and a group so
often the targets of violence and
discrimination even in this country even
just a couple weeks ago
but what we did in that school was to
prototype a concept with application far
beyond our specific group and the
private school setting and i have to say
i haven't seen anything quite like it
i'm proud that the alums of that course
have become those connected and critical
citizens working in everything from our
national defense and intelligence to
representing the under represented
before our u.s supreme court
facing all of our story as a nation in
an honest and questioning spirit only
fueled their engagement and their
intense dedication to our country their
resilience to keep working on problems
especially in times of crisis in their
lives from 9 11 through now
how will we motivate our public school
students to locate themselves as
creators of a more perfect union
how is it possible to draw lessons about
the dynamics between one's own ideals
and group pressure
if you don't learn about the
three-fifths compromise and sit for a
while in shame and embarrassment as well
as understanding of political strategy
in the times
how is it possible for our students to
learn about the inner challenges of
leadership what it's like to sit where
you sit where we hope they will one day
sit and want to unless they can probe
thomas jefferson in both his idealism
and his cowardice
why bother reading thorough if we don't
allow students to take seriously his
indictments of the nation and even of
his own friends
how can we study twain without asking
whether he was lampooning the racism of
his time or swept up in it
sometimes as teachers we have to make
sure that a perspective that was or is
in our history that is so opposite of
what a patriot teacher like me would
ever want to entertain or say out loud
is made vivid and alive in our class
so students know what's at stake
slaveholder perspective stalinist
perspective so it can be addressed in
the safe and trusting container of our
classrooms
if the creators of divisive concepts
laws such as the existing one are
concerned about this country lapsing
into an unpatriotic socialism well it is
the hallmark of socialist dictatorships
to write laws that hide their
implications behind innocent words to
sow doubt about whether you or someone
else is breaking the law to create a
situation where an official or another
citizen can take legal action against
you or just threaten to do that which is
exactly as we know what's happened in
new hampshire and elsewhere with such
laws members of my jewish community have
lived under such laws in our era in
other lands which is why they came here
i've had conversations with people
running for school board or attending
their meetings they happened at my kids
school it's in my american neighborhood
and there's never any actual incident of
a teacher declaring that someone is
inherently racist or that america is
i've heard of a few times i can't tell
you the name of the school i'm trying to
make sure it doesn't happen here i would
like to talk however to my my fellow
parents about the the context of that
situation because i think it's important
to get into cases like that
but the current law seems to be like
this and it doesn't sound like the
american constitution to me
if that is now how if that is not how
you intended the current law then
consider my remarks to be high school
teacher comments on an essay whose
thesis is confusing it needs a revision
if you are serious about education for a
proud and patriotic american citizenship
not just for diversity but unity a
difficult unity and i hope that you are
then show you are serious by getting
engaged with the fine work of our social
studies leaders and our civic education
thinkers pump more substantive standards
into our system as you've tried to do in
the holocaust and genocide law invest in
the resources and training for our
educators around critical citizenship
and a true patriotism
and in the meantime take these current
words out of the laws and pass hb 1576.
thank you for your time and i would be
happy to respond to any questions
do do you have a copy of the uh what you
just read available for the clerk here
good morning
uh i hope i'm not redundant when i thank
you for your service you are the most
unpaid underpaid i would say
citizen volunteers and thank you for the
hours that you put in
i have to be before i make my remarks i
have to address
uh this mom who spoke a couple minutes
ago
i am a retired uh
i think
teachers should be facilitators
and never
create that kind of bias
in some of the questions that they ask
right the greatest compliment a teacher
can receive
and i and maybe once in my tenure a
student asked me so what do you believe
right
should never be the subject in the
classroom
um
i support the current bill in the
previous one for the following reasons
one and it's been discussed before
new hampshire is a state that believes
in local control
therefore let us trust
our local superintendents and principals
to maintain a high imbalance caliber of
teaching within their schools
if we have
an occasional teacher
that perhaps has gone over the line let
the principals handle that i don't think
the state needs to handle it
two truth be known
instructing at the high school level
means intersecting with four or five
sections of day
of reluctant learners
perhaps you've forgotten your teen years
but is unlikely that you came to class
all five or six a day ready to learn
instead it is a task of every educator
to build energy and intellectual
interest
teenagers by their nature want something
they can relate to that has relevance to
their lives
often something they can debate
talking about dead people and concepts
from the 18th century
are not a central focus for teens who
get most of their information from tick
tock
that's the reality
so a teacher's challenge then is to make
the classroom come alive to invest it
with facts and ideas that both educate
and entice
you need to give us the freedom and
trust to do that
imagine for a moment that we're
discussing declaration of independence
it might be a fascinating subject for
the adults in this room but not so much
for a 16 year old
how to make it come alive knowing that
it will engage students in one class
perhaps that technique will flop in the
next teachers need to have the freedom
to be nimble and spontaneous
mention taxation without representation
and watch eyes glaze over
all right instead it might be more
interesting to ask them
if it was fair for england to impose
taxes for a war that they fought in
america
and that their english brethren paid
higher taxes than they did
right
it might be an effective piece so then
to ask is taxation without
representation a piece of disinformation
and to wake a teenager up you might even
say fake news
as a question not a statement
to students
why should we have taxes anyway asked
another student are we allowed to talk
about in the classroom socialists
finland and sweden where education and
medical costs are not crippling expenses
not in the testimony of the bill i heard
a couple weeks ago
or another example
why did jefferson delete from his
initial draft of the declaration and
what did he delete
answer
if you don't know it was on slavery a
condemnation of slavery
so should the ensuing discussion be
limited
fearful of saying something deemed
un-american or ideological
or rather should it ask the question
why do we think he deleted that
paragraph what might it tell us about
america at the time
what might it tell us about the context
that these politicians and founders were
our institute is to get our challenges
to get students to think more deeply to
be critical and fair thinkers
in reality as a as a teacher you're
trying to find a middle ground between
your passion
and acknowledging youth's limited
experience
the beauty of history and i used to say
this to my students all the time is 20
years from now you'll love it
right it's nuances in its complexity
but we do them in injustice if we do not
explore the complexity and the
contradictions of jefferson and even
lincoln
i want my students not only to
understand but operate but appreciate
operating
in the context of their times and
importantly how these issues of the 18th
and 19th and 20th century
are not merely history
but a continuum of an experiment called
the american experience
the study of history is a conversation
where we should be the umpire with its
many twists and turns
let us as a state be self-confident
enough to be self-critical let us be
trusting enough to believe in our
teachers who beyond i think health care
workers have had the most difficult time
in this pandemic
let us create an educational template
that will encourage young people to
become teachers encourage teaching
professionals to want to be in the state
of new hampshire
thank you
thank you very much are there questions
from the committee
yes represent lakers
thank you
i noticed your comment um
initially about what the
one of the former
speakers was talking about
and you agreed that teachers should not
be doing that am i correct no no i would
say the way the questions were asked i
think teachers
i for example would have given out a
primary source instead of a secondary
source right i certainly wouldn't
discourage a student from finding
additional sources i mean to me
you know if i wouldn't get uh fired i'd
give that student a hug for bringing in
additional sources
so so my question then is
if a teacher is doing that and is
limiting
students responses and a student's
research etc
what do you think should be
do you think anything should be done
i think
every profession
we continue to learn
so
my reaction to that is if i were a
parent i would bring my concern to the
principal
or the dean and let's have a
conversation with the teacher
about what they're teaching and how
they're teaching it i don't know if
that's a young teacher i don't know if
that's an experienced teacher but um
not to watch too poetic but i mean
teaching's an art form
and it can always be improved on
so that's what i would have done with
her concern thank you yeah
thank you very much representative
tanner
thank you and thank you for coming i'm
over here thank you thank you for coming
and sharing uh the wonderful story that
you did
um
i was wondering if you would also uh
agree
that
um a new teacher
or a teacher who feels that they're
under the constraints of a vague law
like we have
might
resort to
framed questions from a workbook
or
perhaps limit sources just uh as a
because they don't
because teaching is an art form and you
actually i'm sure
taught differently at the end of your
career than you did the first or second
day of your career
and maybe talk to that if you could
please no thank you for the question and
you're absolutely right right i mean i
i'm i'm glad there's no video of me as a
young teacher
um
i think that that that it may have come
from the workbook and i i mean i don't
want to miss my message here i
i i think our teachers our young
teachers our experienced teachers can't
go into the classroom looking over their
shoulders they can't
i mean some of the best teaching is a
question that you did not expect
and you know as a good teacher you need
to turn that around probably at first
glance back to the classroom
as a neutral question but i can't at the
moment that i'm trying to take these
reluctant learners and they are keep
them engaged and energetic and then at
the same time thinking is that a
question i can respond to
so i i think we have to be careful there
i don't think we want to get overwhelmed
by if there are teachers out there
teaching ideology they shouldn't be
but um
i don't think that's what we're doing as
a profession
thank you very much
uh thank you for coming in today and
sharing your wisdom are you welcome it's
good to be old
thank you mr chair members of the
committee my name is michael o'brien
here on behalf of aft new hampshire i am
a lobbyist with party strategies
here today in support of this bill
after new hampshire was one of
the folks who filed a lawsuit
because our members were getting from
our members that the law was vague
enough that they were concerned about
how they should teach and what they
should teach and how they should
approach their lessons and it was
causing them to step back from important
topics that need to be discussed in the
classroom
you have written testimony from
president deb howes and so i'm going to
keep this pretty short i do want to say
this is personal for me on a separate
level my wife is a history teacher i
have four children one of whom is now
old enough to be in school the other
three who will get there soon um and i
want them to learn those concepts and my
my wife as a history teacher wants to be
able to teach
students so that they can learn and grow
and these are high school students who
she wants to challenge right and wants
them to think critically about important
issues
and so
and and i see her as we talk about the
struggles of teachers
i think i work pretty hard
i work
it pales in comparison to how hard my
wife's job has been and how hard she has
worked over the past three years and
really ever since i've known her but
these past three years have been
exceptionally difficult and when people
have questions about material or
something that she wants that she has
presented in the classroom she spends
hours a night answering emails from
students and parents alike she is
accessible she is there to answer
questions and to help to guide these
students and these parents through any
questions they may have the idea that
teachers are not accessible now in in
this day and age is one of fallacy right
each teacher has an email
these emails are there to be answered
they answer these emails i see her again
spend hours into the night answering
these so
from an aft perspective the law causes
our members
significant apprehension around topics
they should be teaching from a personal
perspective
it is hard for me to see my wife with
the work that she puts in and then be
questioned the way that i think this
committee sort of questions educators in
general around these topics and so for
that we support this bill i'm happy to
take any questions thank you very much
are there quite representative luna
thank you very much mr chair thank you
very much um
mr o'brien for joining us this morning
so
um when um
when
particularly teachers who teach social
studies
or history
um
a handful of short videos from the
department of education in connection
with black history month
um
and particularly in view of
what's currently in statute in these two
areas and one um
would
would would it be your opinion that that
not you know
not not only just with the statutes in
place but now being provided specific
curriculum
that that that touches on this area that
that would
be seen as a broadening um uh
opportunity for teachers or something
that
would could be considered as narrowing
um the the curriculum being taught for
example this is what you should show
your students
sure thank you for the question and i
think that will depend largely on the
teacher and i think there will be
teachers who will see this as this is
what i should be instructing uh for sure
right and i think again it depends on
the teacher's tenure and how long and
how comfortable they are in the
classroom and um how comfortable they
are with the law as written right and
maybe
to some teachers will be that you know
last year a law was passed that said
that i am not fully understanding and
that makes me
be cautious of what i am teaching and
now i'm getting something that this is
my fill in the blank um and i think
those videos and i've watched the ones
that were out um
are
need questions afterwards right they
need context so why these folks uh
booker t washington created these
schools right and
but why was difficult that he did that
that question wasn't posed in those
videos and that can be added that's not
a shot at the video but just to say
teachers can add context to those videos
but some probably wouldn't feel
comfortable under the this law as
written so
i will
i'm still trying to understand the
vagueness of the law so
you've heard the things your your wife
has said etc can you enlighten me in
what it is about the law that
she isn't understanding
uh i would leave her to to to do that i
will just say that when i read her the
the guidance that came from
um the doe and from the ag she uh still
had significant questions about where
that line was and she's been doing this
for a while now um and so she's not you
know new at this anymore but still had
those questions thank you
further questions
not seeing it thank you very much thank
you
good afternoon
members of the house education committee
i want to thank you for taking my
testimony
my name is andrew benfield i'm a
resident of northampton in new hampshire
i'm also parental rights advocate in the
state many of you know me so i've been
doing this for quite a while my focus is
on academic excellence and education
in 2021 we saw an influx of the
radicalized critical race theory
training for teachers
and curriculum aimed at children in
public schools
this came in under the umbrella of
diversity equity and inclusion and
justice
it was so alarming to teachers and
children that many of them mobilized to
affirm our civil rights through the
non-discriminatory language that was
passed in hb2
we saw teacher training in sau 16 that
described everyone
as white supremacists
if they believed in the color blind
society
similar to what this
sponsor brought up just a few minutes
ago
he would like to see a colorblind
society guess what according to
teacher training under two revolutions
that would be considered white
we had parents assuring their children
that they were not responsible for
slavery after receiving
a lesson in history that placed the
actions of slave owners on young
children sitting in our classrooms today
i've talked to these parents
i sent you
my testimony via email you will see her
post on social media where she has to
console her young daughter
that she is not responsible for slavery
a new hampshire
parent
these are violations of the civil rights
act but parents and teachers do not want
to have to take their school district to
court there are costs involved and it
can be a lengthy process as we are
seeing in sau 16 right now
the district has taxpayer-funded
attorneys at their disposal so it can be
a daunting task to spend thousands of
dollars
on a private attorney to fight for our
basic civil rights
currently there is an ongoing lawsuit
sau 16 where a resident is just trying
to compile documents to look at how crt
was implemented in the school district
residents are already already uncovered
information that shows that they were
planning to push more bias and prejudice
on students
the superintendent is using
taxpayer-funded school district
attorneys to fight against produce
producing these documents and when i
filed the right to no request the last
time
they had already spent ten thousand
dollars on their attorney fees fighting
in court to produce these documents
we do know that sau 16 purchased books
for the students on anti-racism
anti-racism includes the same toxicity
toxicity as the radicalized critical
race theory that we are seeing in public
schools today
for instance in the book sau 16
purchased for 8th grade children the
author says that you
all of us are in two categories
so either you fit into the dominant
culture if you are white upper middle
class cisgender male educated athletic
neurotypical able-bodied
if you don't fit into this class you're
in the subordinate culture
those in the subordinate culture
identify as brown indigenous people of
color of the global majority queer
transgender non-binary cisgender women
youth muslim jewish buddhist atheists
non-christian no diverse those living
with disabilities are those living in
poverty and more
a student or teacher must then determine
which of those two box boxes that
student fits in
and this is why condoleezza rice
rejected this whole notion
and she said it on the view if you go
and and
in my um
testimony to you i i put the link in
there
and she talks about how we are
discussing race relations in the
classroom today she disagreed with
requiring white people to feel guilty
for everything that has happened in the
past
she mentions one of the most important
features of crt which is the idea
that black people have to feel
disempowered
she rejects this worldview and goes on
to say that she wants black kids to be
completely empowered
to know that they are beautiful in their
blackness what a wonderful statement
but in order to do that she doesn't want
to make white kids feel bad for being
white which is what we're seeing in new
hampshire
condoleezza rice just summed up why crt
agenda is wrong for students in new
hampshire
while this may be wrong the crt deij
anti-racist agenda also violates our
basic civil rights
those rights were affirmed in hb2 with
the anti-discrimination language
why would anyone think it's okay to
discriminate against any group of people
based on their skin color
why would we want to go backwards
why would you not want to affirm our
civil rights of all the children in
teachers
in our public schools because i've heard
from teachers too now will you get them
here absolutely not they're not going to
put their job on the line
but they are getting pressure from the
administrators bringing in the
professional development
this kind of discriminatory behavior has
been happening in many other schools
like litchfield sanborn
exeter hollis brookline and hopkinton to
name a few
parents have set up websites you can
find the link in your email
facebook pages have objected to this
discriminatory behavior at school board
meetings hb2 has helped those parents
and teachers require their school
administrators to go back to focusing on
academic achievement for all of their
students
teachers are in a very difficult
position speaking publicly but hb2 has
also helped them so they are not just
subjected to this kind of hate and
prejudice from professional development
it was david ryan superintendent of sau
16 who admitted
in a public meeting that they would have
to change their professional development
because of this anti-discriminatory law
the professional development and sau 16
provided by two revolutions
was questioned at a public meeting when
somebody asked about the professional
development the east kingston teachers
had to endure
and i give you a link to where he makes
this public statement
according to two revolutions teachers
and children are covert racists and
white supremacists if they are number
one
of the belief that we should be
colorblind when judging someone
number two if we are silent and we don't
speak up
number three are white parents
self-segregating in certain
neighborhoods and schools
live in an area where education funding
is from property taxes
supports the message of make great make
america great again denies white
privilege believes in exceptionalism you
are a white supremacist that's what the
teachers were learning
celebrates columbus day
claims reverse racism
assumes good intentions are enough
believes that we're all one big human
family there's only one human race
you're a white supremacist
this is the kind of professional
development we have seen in new
hampshire schools this is not training
that is focused on helping students
succeed academically but training
teachers to blame and shame their
colleagues and the children in their
care and i heard from teachers who have
been blamed and shamed by their
colleagues
for their white supremacists and they
the teachers in sau 16 were subjected to
professional development by two
revolutions who was hired to work with
the teachers
according to two revolutions if you live
in an area that funds public education
through property taxes you are a white
supremacist
that would mean that every resident in
new hampshire is a white supremacist
including all of you
sitting on this committee
if children happen to be in a
subordinate culture remember you're in
two you're one or the two children may
begin viewing themselves as abnormal and
inferior that's what condoleesa rice was
concerned about
how is it good for black how is that
good for black and brown children
condoleezza rice said it best when she
said she wanted black and brown children
to feel empowered and beautiful in their
blackness
what a wonderful statement
there are many more examples i can share
but i think you can see the kind of
destructive bias we saw in new hampshire
schools prior to the passage of
hb2 this was damaging to teachers and
children in our public schools
there is now a way for parents and
teachers to fight back against the
prejudice aimed at them
they shouldn't be used as a political
tool by political radicals our schools
should be focused on academic excellence
and literacy in the core subjects
that is how you uplift all children
that is how you support public schools
in new hampshire
so for these reasons i ask you to reject
or to vote itl on 1576 which would also
include hb 1090.
that concludes my um
my uh
testimony but i would like to go back
and just talk about a couple of things
somebody brought up the book stamped i
think it was megan tuttle brought up
this book stamp that um
it's being um
possibly removed in some of these
classes let me tell you about the book
stamped
okay it's written by ibram x kendi and i
was contacted by a hopkinson parent who
said that her daughter was required to
read this book the entire year she
removed her daughter from school by the
way
because that's what these things do is
they they cause parents to remove their
kids from schools
ibra makes kendi in that book admits
because i read the book that he is not a
historian
he's giving
historical parts he's talking about
historical events
and for instance the parent who actually
read the book
said that
there's misleading information in that
book
about the louisiana purchase for
instance maybe he's left out information
um things like that so some of these
books that may be removed may be removed
because if you're teaching history you
want it actually authentic and maybe
taught by a historian
or somebody who knows the subject
and so while he may have his views
that's great but
if you're if your child's in a class in
a history or social studies class maybe
you want authentic history maybe you
want the full picture
fiction picture being told
and ibrahmax candy said
in a tweet
some white colonizers adopted black
children they civilized these savage
children in the superior ways of white
people
while using them as props and their
lifelong pictures of denial while
cutting
the biological parents of these children
out of the picture of humanity so maybe
maybe the book is being removed because
of a political activist book in the in a
history class versus somebody who
actually wants to teach the subject and
teach it well
um so what kind of chilling effect does
this have did this have
well as rebecca said
the new hampshire parent
i just can't my nine-year-old asked me
this weekend if slavery was her fault
because she's a white person
we have an open question answer about
anything and she is super interested in
rosa parks and the underground railroad
we happened to be in boston when she
asked this one i guess we pro i guess we
probably need to separate a separate
facebook page look in her eyes thinking
that slavery was her our fault
is crushing
that's what the parents said and that is
included in your in your email to you
so that's the chilling effect so i'm not
sure what the answer is i don't
understand why
um because as i read as i read the
actual language in the discriminatory
law
it focuses on discrimination it means
don't blame and shame kids don't blame
and shame
teachers that you don't know
i don't understand how that's difficult
to implement in the classroom
you know somebody said trust let's trust
well
i can give you so many examples of
if it these teachers don't want to
sometimes teach it this way but the
administrators have brought it in in
professional development said this is
what you're going to do so you can take
it to the trust like i mean quite
frankly i trust this guy back here
teaching the kids i mean what he
explained i think is what most people
would want out of a social studies
teacher but that's not what we're seeing
that's not what we're seeing please do
your research this has been going on for
the past year i know
i don't really think i have anything
other than that to say but
other than if you're going to repeal
anything then you better fix this
problem in the process because it won't
be fixed if you repeal it
thank you very much are there questions
yes representative porter thank you mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question ms beansville were you present
at the professional development um
opportunities that the teachers had in
your sau that you talked about that were
so upsetting where these things were
said and done
no i was not at the actual professional
development what we did is we we
obtained information we detained
documents on what two revolutions
provides and i provided that to you in
there is a um as you'll see in your
email
there is a um pyramid
pyramid of overt white supremacy which
is socially unacceptable and covert
white supremacy which is socially
acceptable and so you can see what is
provided to the teachers through two
revolutions they were the ones that were
hired to do the professional development
so
this is what this is the documents that
they put out this is what they say this
is what we do as an organization
thank you further questions
thank you very much
hi thank you mr chair for taking my
testimony my name is louise spencer
i am here speaking on my own behalf i
live in concord but i am part of the
kent street coalition
which is an all volunteer grassroots
advocacy group
and i am confident that
that the
folks in that group would agree that
these
bills that we support these bills
and that we would like to see um
the language that was passed in sb2 to
be overturned
i'm speaking here today as a parent
whose children went through
concord public schools
and also as someone who spent most of my
educational experience in public schools
growing up
and
i had a range of
teachers
it's not impos it's not possible for
people to totally
sanitize and sterilize their experience
from who they are
when they enter into the classroom
so i would
could be aware that some were
conservative in their perspective some
were more liberal in their perspectives
some were religious some perhaps not
variety of racial
backgrounds ethnicities
and life experiences
including diversity of socioeconomic
experiences
those things enriched my education
that
was profound
in terms of
how i learned and how i
grew as a person
and i i find it very sad that we're
trying to to
really remove that richness of
experience from our classrooms
i think it's one of our greatest
strengths
as a country is that we are lucky to
have
such a diverse experience and i do not
i also had a wide range of
fellow students again the same range of
experiences again that was enriching my
and
i often heard in school
things that i did not agree with or that
i wasn't taught at home
my children heard such things in school
as well
they came home and we discussed it and
it made for a rich and engaging
conversation
it helped them grow
it helped me grow as a child and i'm
grateful to my parents that what that
one experience that comes to mind for my
daughter was she was in a civics class
in high school and was
was election day and the teacher said
kids asked when are you going to vote
and the teacher said oh i only vote in
presidential elections the rest of
elections are a waste of time
my daughter came home quite appalled by
this
sit by this comment rightly so
she and i had a long discussion along
with my husband about it and how she
might approach that with the teacher
um or if she wanted us to engage the
teacher
she chose to go and speak with the
it became a topic of conversation in the
classroom
and an opportunity for for exploration
it turned into a very rich and powerful
experience rather than what is so often
portrayed as a negative one
um
the other thing that strikes me as i
find it ironic
that
the underlying law
that we're talking about and seeking to
repeal
will make it
so much more likely
that sources that students can reference
will be limited
that's one of the very purposes of the
bill is to put restrictions on what's
available to students to explore and
discuss and discover
so we've already heard about
books that might be pulled from the
classroom or books that might not be
approved
if i were a teacher teaching i will want
to make pretty darn sure that when i
under this law
that i that i direct directed my
students to certain um
websites and resources
lest i be
accused of somehow um
bringing in things that were not
considered acceptable to be discussed
i also know that as a student
at all levels of my education
especially
as i'm thinking from middle school on
but
throughout my education i was encouraged
to look at things from different
perspectives and often i was given
assignments to write not from my own
perspective
but
that from another person how it might
feel to have been an immigrant to this
country
how it might have felt to be
someone who was escaping the holocaust
trying to get students to think about
someone's experience other than their
own life experience
that may mean that certain resources are
limited to the student or certain
things being introduced into an essay
may not actually
address the assignment as given
it's important that we understand that
what the teacher is trying to teach when
a certain assignment is given
and i think if we have any question
about the ambiguity of this law we need
only look at the testimony today it was
all over
the
place quite frankly about whether this
was about limiting whether it meant that
we
and by the law i mean the law as it
currently exists doesn't mean we can't
teach about racism does it mean we can't
teach about what racism looked like in
the past is it about crt is it about
diversity and inclusion
i think it's disingenuous when we are
asked to deny the
the origins of this particular bill and
the language
from which it arose
which was hb 544
the divisive concept spill
upon which
chris ruffo came in and spoke and was
very clear about the ties to divisive
language and i think the effort to make
the language more ambiguous
quite frankly is to make it more
difficult for us to really have an on
honest conversation about what this bill
actually is attempting to do because no
you cannot go by it word by word and
point to a specific thing in it that's
the very point
it's the overall impact of this bill and
we're hearing it here today
it it's the chilling effect and that's
the intention of this bill and it's not
contained in any particular word it's
contained in the way it's played out
it's contained in the way that
there are bounties put on teachers
it's contained in the way that if you go
on social media and look
you will find all kinds of
interpretations about what this bill
means and i have to say if i were a
teacher i would that would make me very
nervous
talk about lawsuits and being afraid of
those
as a teacher i would
be worried about having to defend myself
and possibly losing my um
my livelihood so
um
that's my testimony i thank you for
giving me the time to share it thank you
very much are there questions from the
committee
yes
thank you ms cheer thank you for your
testimony
there are communist
i i'm a history guy and i hate to use
the word communist because it conjures
up joe mccarthy but let me get to it
there are schools that have had
communist clubs
and the purpose of the expressed dark
communist doctrine is to replace our our
uh existing structures with with
something
totally
different from what we have
so are you comfortable with communist
clubs in high schools
um
i'm not i would have to look more
carefully at the law but i think that
schools in terms of clubs are are fairly
limited in what they
when what students want to do on their
private
um
you know after school in terms of clubs
i i think that
i would have to defer to the lawyers on
that but i think there's a wide range
considerations that schools have to take
so it's not really up to me of whether i
would be comfortable with that kind of a
club or not it's really about
what
the law
provides because also you might have
clubs that are
religious clubs or other political
perspectives if you start limiting one
perspective then you may well be getting
into an area where you're limiting other
perspectives so i i would
i can't really speak to what i would do
about
a club like that
thank you
are there further questions
thank you for your testimony today um
and you talked about the chilling effect
on teachers do you think this has a
chilling effect on the kids in the
classroom as well
i do i do and i
you know i
i think we have to think about all the
kids in the classroom um
and
the ways in which
they may feel
if they know a book's been pulled from
the classroom that has to do with lgbtq
issues
and they're an lgbt kid cube
um kid
how is that going to make that child
feel
um
i
i don't think any children should be
with
the problems that adults current and
past have created
on the other hand i think when a child
asks a question like was i responsible
for slavery
or
is there something wrong with me because
i am lgbtq and i wanted to read that
book or
any number of questions that a child
might emerge from the classroom with
i think it's important that hopefully
they can have those conversations with
their parents
um
but i i think that
it's
there are a lot of ways children can be
impacted
across the board
based on their experiences and i think
we have to be
be careful and mindful of that but i
don't think a law like this
and when i keep saying a lot like this
i'm referring to the underlying law
does anything to help us address those
sorts of challenges that children might
face growing up in this very difficult
and challenging world
and trying to seek answers
so further questions represent allison
uh just a quick question a follow-up to
representative moffat's question
uh are you aware of any communist clubs
in any schools in new hampshire i am not
do we need any more questions on that
topic
thank you very much
okay we have a question right here
representative moffat
your famous chair uh
and representative
mentioned my
my question and i asked the question
because uh
concord high school at least in the past
i've seen yearbooks where they have the
communist club in the yearbook
so that caught my eye and i don't know
it's in the euro it was i don't know if
it still is in the yearbook so that's
where that question came from
and it caught my eye and
i my question is
what had to do with is a sanction is
there a school advisor for the communist
club
that i don't know if that's the case but
that's the question i and others have
had um to respond i can't speak to that
um
i i have no knowledge of that so
represent woodcock do you have a
question i do but not for not before
everything i'm offered
because the school doesn't know there's
the state law is clear on that
oh yes for her exactly yes thank you so
much
thank you so much to my question i just
want to read this and unfortunately the
lawyer left i want to read a statement
from the last
portion of the aclu testimony and just
get your opinion if you agree or
disagree
it says in schools we should be allowing
ideas to be discussed
even those we do not agree with so
students are exposed to alternative
perspectives and are taught to evaluate
issues for themselves
would you is that something you would
agree with or not agree with i strongly
agree with that thank you thank you
further questions from the committee now
seeing anne's thank you very much okay
thank you so much
and i made it clear i
i am in support of this bill i also want
to make clear i'm in support of the
prior bill as well
i think 1090
the two bills seeking repeal thank you
good afternoon and thank you for having
me today
um i am here in support
of house bill
accidentally giving away too many copies
um
good afternoon i'm here representing um
can you please move the mic a little
closer to you yes can you hear me now
better yes
i'm here representing new futures i am
the children's behavioral health policy
coordinator there i did forget my badge
today i'm sorry
new futures is a non-partisan non-profit
organization that advocates educates and
collaborates to improve the health and
wellness of all new hampshire residents
new futures is also the new hampshire's
authorized kids count organization and
so we
advocate for data-based policies that
support granite state families
new futures stands in strong support of
house bill 1576 and the previous bill
1090.
this bill would repeal the divisive
concepts bills that passed last year and
would allow granite state teachers
students and professionals to once again
discuss learn about and ultimately work
to address many of the issues that
directly impact the health and wellness
of granite staters
from a public health standpoint there is
a clear evidence that inequalities and
disparities disproportionately affect
people of color and women across new
hampshire this is evidenced in
new hampshire fiscal policy institute
data that we've cited in our written
testimony
according to the u.s census bureau as
well individuals across new hampshire
who identify as african-american
hispanic or other communities of color
report significantly lower income and
higher poverty levels than the statewide
average these disparities extend across
to education child care housing and
other social determinants of health
and they impact the health and wellness
of our entire state
to address these inequalities it's
important that students have the
opportunity to learn about the systems
in place that
um that uh encourage these inequalities
and learn how to address them in a safe
and
controlled manner like in a classroom
they're encouraged to just explore
historical cultural and institutional
forces that contribute to and reinforce
these disparities
without learning about these issues and
exploring them in the classroom
our citizens nor our state will be able
to address them and we will not be able
to support all of our children and
families to become safe healthy and
equitable place we hope new hampshire to
be
for these reasons new futures supports
house bill 1576 and encourages this
committee to
recommend that this bill ought to pass
thank you very much are there questions
from the presenter no thank you very
much
uh is kyle's business
his business
he's he's already gone
we'll go to the next person
um
is this
art
it's from kensington i have enough
al okay
all
thank you and i know it's past lunch
time and i really appreciate
everything that you guys are doing here
and and i appreciate your dedication i
know how hard this is
uh or i can only imagine
first i want to start out maybe with a
little bit of levity because um i'm not
a mafia mafia kingpin i'm italian right
and this is what happens 30 years ago
i came to new hampshire and
we went to ride buy a piece of land and
when we did my wife and i uh the real
estate agent said looked at me and said
i'm really sorry but we
we can't sell they're not going to sell
you the house and i said why they said
well
you're italian this is 30 years ago in
rye
and um he looked at my wife and he said
how about you she has red hair and blue
eyes irish looking but her last name was
scaglione that wasn't going to work
either so neither to say we didn't move
to rye
but the fact of the matter is that's
what i'm trying to i understand
everybody in this room i understand what
they feel
but
but it's emotionally based right we all
come through it this is the melting pot
this is america
from one come many and that's what we
really have to concentrate on
from one many
and i know a little bit about crt and
deij
i'm a grandfather i take care of my
granddaughter and one of the big
problems was when she came home one day
and she said you know what grandpa
i don't i don't like being white i'm
like what are you talking about you
don't like being white
i didn't believe that and then then it
was
the one that got me probably even worse
was christopher columbus right
christopher columbus didn't like
christopher columbus anymore he's
she's 10 years old i'm like what are you
talking about so i took the time to go
to the school and look at curriculums
and go to school board meetings i had
never been involved before
and i was horrified horrified to the
fact that unfortunately i'm spending a
small fortune in a lawsuit right now for
a right to know
that has been incredibly a huge burden
upon my family
but it's impossible to get information
one of the things i did learn is that
the curriculums are not there what
happens is it's buried in the teacher
training and the teacher training when
you go look at the curriculum it's not
what they're teaching it's
they teach the teachers to teach
something else
and this gentleman behind us i i would
do anything to have my granddaughter
have a teacher like that
oh my god it would be fantastic
unfortunately the ideal ideology is
being taught to the teachers
and that's where the problem is that's
where it's happening i know it well i
sit before you having to spending a
small fortune
to defend a right to no law in the state
of new hampshire
one thing i want to pass on to you is
crt and deij undermine dr king we all
grew up we're all a product i look
around we all have i like to say snow on
the roof but our boiler's still hot
right we we're all here but dr king
taught us it's what we we're all came
from
right
character of a color and i don't want
people to see me as a mafia kingpin i
don't want anyone to see any of these
other people in any other light just as
americans
from one many
i will close with we can't regulate
emotion we can't regulate feelings
but remember if we a republic can't
stand uh if it's divided
thank you
thank you very much are there any
questions for the presenter
nazi thank you very much
uh is kimberly
cato
uh kimberly you wrote down 15 minutes
we're gonna have to cut that down
significantly for me
i asked for patience and forgiveness
i've never done this before so
um
i'm not a professional speaker
i'm not a professional any capacity
i've lived in new hampshire my entire
life
my family came from canada and worked in
the mills
my grandfather was a fireman for 30
years
he went to world war ii
um
i'm here in capacity just as a mom
a regular mom
who sees what's going on
i have a beautiful
nine-year-old son
and i really want to implore to
everybody here
that this is about
the kids in new hampshire
this is about our children and they
don't deserve to be told
that they are
oppressors or bad people
based on immutable qualities we should
not put up with treating our own kids
the way that we would never stand for
any other people's kids to be treated we
would never say
oh you're uh african so you need to
you need to take responsibility for the
cannibalism
and genocide that happened in your
country in your
continent
you know every
to put in a more personal level
everybody has a story
everybody has a history what's important
is what you do with that history and i
don't think
that any of this that's going on right
now i don't think it's accidental that
it's happening when most of the world
war ii vets are gone because i think
they would be ashamed they would be
ashamed of what is happening and that
americans are not standing up for
american principles
which is equality
everybody should be treated the same and
you should be rewarded or punished
on your own merits that's what america
is
and when i have to talk to my
nine-year-old because he's in school
and every book that he looks at
there's no white people in it
um
if there is a white person in it they're
a bad person
or they're stupid or they're doing
something wrong
we would not stand for that
if it was a black
any other kind of person
right now um
everybody's pretending and having this
like well what is crt it's so nebulous
it's very clear and it's very simple the
one thing to remember is crt is
anti-white training it is training
to disparage your own country
and nobody should be disparaging your
own country everybody has a history
everybody has a story would you tell a
drug addict
you did some things so therefore you
have to suffer for the rest of your life
or just go die you would never say that
and our country as a whole we should be
proud of what our history is
we've gone through so much
um
i really am imploring people to not fall
we need to stand for our citizens and
stand for america um
the one thing uh
that is observably true
is that since this crt
has been brought up and being argued
about
violence against white people has
increased by multiple factors of 100s
just some small examples the waukesha
christmas parade which was clearly a
racial crime intended to kill as many
white people as possible
canon henat
a very small young boy who was murdered
because he was white
a boy named emmanuel was thrown from a
balcony in a mall
um
a 12 year old boy was stabbed in the
neck at mcdonald's standing in line by a
black man
all of these children were murdered
by black people who have gone
over the edge because they are receiving
this crt anti-white training which is
teaching them that all white people are
horrible all white people are bad
um and policy makers are doing
everything they can to disadvantaged
already marginalize and disenfranchise
white people the largest population of
people in america living in abject
poverty are white people
so you want to have teachers
telling these low-income white children
and especially the little boys
they're they're not born nobody is born
an awful person
to be oh look
this is white man this is white man well
i don't know about you but i'm actually
proud of white men i think white men
have done great things in this world and
what done great things in this country
they should be learning that's
just as much as learning difficult
things nobody's talking about oh um
you're trying to ruin our freedom of
speech no
you know what we're talking about here
is saying we as parents do not want
teachers abusing our children ruining
their self-esteem
and making them feel like
there's some original sin that they can
never get over jesus died on the cross
because our sins are forgiven everyone's
sins are forgiven
and um
also i have an uncle my grandmother's
brother excuse me uh we don't you're
gonna have to cut this uh kind of short
here oh
that's fine yeah that's fine
that's fine um
the other thing that ken is searchable
is that uh
this idea of diversity being the
greatest strength is actually the
greatest weakness
um
anybody that's been to prison
understands racial violence
understands how things naturally shake
out in prisons
prisons have actually
wanted to
institute segregation to keep people
safe
because can you please wrap it up you're
you're working yeah i understand where
you're coming from and i hear exactly
what you're saying
please stand up for the children no
white children deserve to be taught if
you can call it that
by activists that they're bad or there's
something wrong with their country that
is communist and it's anti-american
thank you very much
this guy's gone right here
john's best of that
yeah we're done
yes
thank you mr shirt and thank you members
of the committee
and again my name is
maria perez
i'm a state representative for this 23.
let me put my thoughts together here
first of all
i want to say that um
i'm very grateful to
to live in this country i'm very
grateful as an immigrant
who
often
from the world and el salvador
and when someone approached me
and it
told me that they know
the pain and the
hurt that i went through
and they understand they understand the
background
why that i'm here
and why that i migrated from my country
i'm grateful that someone took the time
and learned
i'm here to support this bill because as
someone
who in 2004
work is a human resource management i
had more than 200 people a week
higher
it's a temporary employers with
different backgrounds and different
cultures
it is critical
for people who
have these positions
and it's critical for us
when we go to college
for human resource management for
business administration
anything like that it's good for us to
learn the history
for me it was critical to learn the
history to get my citizenship
i bet you the many other people
who criticize and teachers for teaching
history that has to go through the
citizenship test that we have to go
through as an immigrant to get a
citizenship
so i'm grateful that the teachers are
teaching history
because
it helped us to understand
what a great
country this is full of many different
backgrounds many different cultures
that help us to be grateful to learn
and to appreciate every human being
for that reason
i will ask this committee to support
this
to support this field
thank you very much representative are
there any questions for the
representative
not seeing any thank you very much
we do not have any additional cards up
here
we have another hearing starting in
but we're gonna have to have a lunch
first so we'll break for a lunch and
start later
i'll let you know in a minute
representative ham is out in the hallway
i'm with um rights and democracy but i'm
also here speaking as an immigrant as a
proud brown woman standing before you
and as a proud muslim woman
i wanted to share a few remarks i sat
here
and listened to people
dismissing scholars
and real experiences
i sat here
and listened to parents
comparing my and my communities real
lived experiences as being targeted as
terrorists with their experiences of
feeling that they're being attacked
because of educational beliefs
not the same
i sat here and listened to people saying
they no longer see white people in books
i'm not going to respond to that you
pick up any book and see if that's true
i sat here and listened to people say
that black people are killing white
people
and you all heard this
i sat here and listened to a gentleman
talk about the italians being attacked
and he is very right and he is very true
the irish were also attacked the jews
were also attacked he is absolutely
correct and i want to remind everyone
all those people we were just that just
were mentioned were not considered white
once upon a time the standard was
whiteness
i am disheartened when our truths are
spoken people feel attacked
it is uncomfortable to hear our
experiences why
if it's uncomfortable to hear our
experiences i ask you
if all of you are okay with the fact
that the majority of people opposing
this bill
have said what they said
and you will still vote against this
i believe in the goodness of humanity
let's put party lines aside today and
let's do the right thing
people deserve to share their truths
we live in a country where everyone
deserves the same rights
you you you and me too
we can get there
we can get there but we can't get there
if we're banning people from speaking
their truths
and when teachers are afraid to share
our truths
i'm appealing to your humanity today and
to say please pass this law
enough is enough
we need the multi-racial democracy that
we're all after there's space for
everyone in this country
thank you
thank you very much
any questions from the committee
not saying thank you with that we're
okay are there any people sitting in the
no
and uh representative hamps in the
hallway
i'll go speak with her so uh
i i think everybody here is deserving an
opportunity to at least walk down the
hallway
maybe a little farther
uh but also to have put some nourishment
and some fluids in you um it's very dry
in this room and get some fluids in you
so we're going to take a break here and
we'll pick this thing up at 25 minutes
after
okay
foreign
hey
oh
you
excuse me i'm bonnie ham i represent
lincoln woodstock in waterville and i'm
here to introduce
uh and support house bill 1152
and what it does is it just clarifies in
the lord it may be in there
but i'm not sure clarifies in the law
that
if um a student
that qualified
for an education um
freedom account
the student no longer
qualifies for
free or reduced lunch
that
that he would not get the free or
reduced lunch in other words
that this should that we should look at
the income
qualifications annually to make sure
that the students
still is eligible
to receive the differential aid
under the law
and that's all it does
just to make sure they still meet the
requirements before they get their
thank you chairman thank you
see you again uh it's how to follow that
it is just uh
relative to this
uh
why wouldn't
what were you thinking that we didn't
include that the
verification for uh annual eligibility
would be just beyond differential
i mean if i understand the law correctly
which i may not but if i do
they verify initially they verified for
the for the life of their program why
wouldn't we want to as well as uh this
aid and any other aid and reduced lunch
why would we want the law to be
encompassing the the
annual review of eligibility for
financial
i i think i think that would be a good
idea
to annually check the eligibility
from
more than one point of view to make sure
that they still qualify
for their
aid i think that would be a good idea if
there's other types of aid besides the
lunch
that look at those also
okay thank you thank you chairman
not seeing any hands
where
oh waving way over there in the horizon
represent porter
i told you guys put things in front of
me
so it can't be seen thank you
representative for taking my question so
i want to make sure i understand all
you're asking in this bill is if in the
first year
when a family makes an application
and they qualify for free and reduced
lunch that means the amount of the
voucher that they receive
would include
a differential for being free and
reduced lunch
that they should check again the second
year to make sure right that they still
qualify for free and reduced lunch if
they do
all is copacetic if they don't
then they
then the amount of aid that they receive
might go down
that's exactly correct you never know um
the um student or his family's income
might change
so it makes sense to me to check
annually
um
to see yeah yeah so in the public
schools
they do that every year
i believe so i i think so yeah you have
to put a new application in i i am i'm
fairly sure um
that the parents apply annually i'm
pretty sure that so it would be the same
same as if if they were in the public
school
not asking for any more to have it
yes represents
are you aware that every year the
um
parents have to put in a new income
and all of their w-2s and whatever
every year and every year the
scholarship organization does check
because that's how they determine how
much money each student should get each
year and they do this already every year
that could very well be the case i just
want to make sure it's there that that
the lunch is also included and all the
other things that they check
just seems like a fairness issue to me
it's what happens in the public schools
and i would think this is an alternative
type education that that the same
standard should apply
to those that are taking advantage of
the education freedom account
represent woodcock
just trying to get a clarification and
you may or let me know i don't know i'm
not i'm not trying to probably just
don't know um because i was reading and
i just heard what representative lika
said i was reading
lines four and five in this bill
and i thought in the efa account i may
be wrong and so i want to clarify here i
thought in the efa accounts that that
once a student was enrolled at the
initial threshold within that 300 level
threshold
that income eligibility maintained
itself for the duration of the efa
um i thought that's what it was and that
this bill
the president brandon just dealt with
differential aid but i just heard
representatives say just the opposite
that's annually evaluated so do either
one of you gentlemen know the correct
answer
uh well we could do that an exact
session but i'll let representative
cordelli give you that response now
thank you thank you thank you i i think
you're
correct in that if you look at line
seven no income threshold need be met in
subsequent years
right what is recalculated is the amount
of their grant based on adequacy and any
differentiated aid
yes that's that is so you'd be checking
for free and reduced meals
and the child may no longer have an iep
too so there wouldn't be any eligibility
under the special education as well or
english language learner
et cetera
do we have any other uh cards for this
one
well that's it we'll close the hearing
and
wish representative ham a wonderful trip
it was miserable this morning
awful
i do have a question about the question
that representative woodcock just asked
about the
income
and eligibility
under the
efa accounts
i'm confused now
my understanding was that there would be
no
further
[Music]
check on the
income
once a family had been accepted into
that program
they were in the program they didn't
have to keep
verifying their income year after year
but now we just found out that they have
to verify their income for free and
reduced lunches
so
if if they don't
i guess i i want to know how that can be
two different things and
i think we in this bill are mixing some
apples with oranges
uh eligibility is correct what represent
woodcock was saying there now
when we talk about adequacy and
differentiated aid that's a different
topic all together and that will change
even the public school for certain
students depending upon whether they
still require that service yes but if
they're looking in order to do that they
have to look at someone's income they
they send that it's it's a
a form which is sent home
you know how that's done yes but they
still look at income
yes they do but that's not for
qualifying to be in to in the program
they're already in the program
now we're looking at and see if they're
still eligible to receive the level of
food services so or
that stuff right so if a parent sends in
their income
to verify for a free and reduced lunch
and the income is too high
to qualify
for an efa account anymore
i don't understand how we would not look
at that
i
i don't understand how we're looking at
income but we're not looking at income
the second year
and the third or you're not looking at
eligibility and that's what this is this
this category of statute we were looking
at
is we're talking about eligible student
and we're talking about eligibility at
the 300 percent level right that's what
we're talking about we've now injected
this other topic in there where i
believe if i were writing this statute i
would not have put it underneath this
particular area of
law and that's something we might want
to discuss
when we're considering this in executive
session
it's just confusing to me because i have
a discussion going on here which we can
do because we're not in hearing right
once the child is accepted into the
program we no longer look at their
as being eligible we no longer look at
their income to see if they're eligible
for the program yes once they do look at
their income to see how much money they
get
how am i whether they get any additional
money or not i understand that i
understand that but my question is
so someone is eligible for the program
in the first year because they are 300
of poverty
year two and and that might make them
eligible for free and reduced lunches as
well
year two they're at 400 percent of of of
free of
poverty which
would
make them ineligible for free and
reduced lunches and also makes them
ineligible for the receiving the program
we're looking at the income it's the
same income
because of the way the bill was written
it was intentionally written
so that once a child was eligible and
started in the program they did not have
to be bumped if their parents
made more money this was the issue in
the i was in the senate hearing just
last week yes and heard all of this
basically
um the whole the whole point was you
don't have a kid coming in and out of a
program based on how well their parents
did that year in income but they do come
in and out of the program for free and
reduced lunches if the parents that's
that's just me
comes in income comes five dollars over
the limit then they're out of the free
and reduced lunch program i mean we do
kick kids out of programs when right but
you don't kick them out of the school
and that's the thing if his kid is going
to a school and using this
or some educational
program provider whatever and find
something that really works say they're
going to the monastery school and this
is what's allowing them and now the
parents make just a little bit more
money we don't kick them out but then
the next year they make a little less so
now they can go to the montessori school
once they're in once they find a program
that works they get to stay and that was
the whole point of that part of the law
what the the checking the
eligibility is is for the extra money so
say they don't need the special needs
aid anymore say
you know that those all those built-in
things that you know that we calculate
all the time
it's they check the income just to see
what the calculation is so eligibility
like he was saying doesn't make sense to
put it here because it's not checking if
they're eligible it's checking just to
see how much money they get
that's it
except it's not the way
other programs that give government
money to people work
it's that's not how it works if you if
you earn more money then you are no
longer eligible and that happens many
times for many programs but uh but the
way this works we're talking adequacy
there's base base cost which is roughly
around thirty seven hundred dollars and
then you have the categorical areas not
categorical but those areas of
differentiated aid those go to every
student
in
in this state whether it's a wealthy
community or a poor community
whether the family is wealthy or not
they
they will get this basic adequacy and if
they qualify as a special ed student
they will get the additional dollar for
that and the others too if they qualify
it's just like if they qualify for
special ed so if someone comes in to
apply for the education freedom account
and their income is 400
of poverty they don't qualify for the
program
that's correct first year
that's that's the way it is
okay
so why would then
a person who gets
300 of poverty the first year 400 of
poverty the second year why would that
not
phase out then
if the person has enough money then
supposedly to pay for their their
tuition to this
to this school it might very well phase
out some of the differentiated aid for
the student that is
uh
in the free reduced meal program
however um there's a lot of other
variables that depend upon the income
the family can increase but so can the
number of kids in the family increase
but that would that would change
according to the poverty level it's a
i'm sorry it's just it's it's the way it
just seems inequitable to me
that someone who is earning more than
you need to get into the program
doesn't have to worry about it anymore
they could you know
get a
becoming at 700 percent of poverty the
second year and still be getting state
money to send their kids to private
school it just
seems because all kids get that money
all kids regardless no because those
kids didn't get that money
if they had 400
poverty they did not get that money to
get into that program originally
if you're a student in the
rigor program
and they have 400 they're at that 400
level they're still going to get their
adequacy and all their differentiated
no i would i would i would agree with
you that it's not fair but my solution
is since all the kids that go to public
school that money gets spent for their
education that all the kids that don't
go to public school should have that
same amount of money and that discon
disallowing them at 300 percent is the
part that's unfair because
most people are trapped in the middle
income area where they can't afford
anything and they don't get scholarships
so
the 300 percent is still
what ends up happening is people move
above that 300 percent now they're
considered middle you know they might be
low middle income they might just be
making a little bit more but now they
get nothing and they can't afford
private school
and that happens with food stamps and
that happens with with
help paying for child care and all those
other programs that people
have that issue in i agree and i think
yeah and that is uh hb 1241
prohibiting a school district from
mandating a covid19 vaccination for
school attendance
[Music]
okay represent tom
lanzaro
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee good to see you again i am tom
linzera a representative from nashua
come before you to introduce house bill
prohibiting a school district for
mandating a covet 19 vaccination for
school attendance
throughout excuse me throughout history
society has always treated the sick not
the healthy
as biological entities we have been
given an immune system purposed with the
task of fighting off those things that
cause infection
proponents of covet vaccinations often
create false parallels between
and also the need for vaccinations
denying the case for natural immunity
while casting aside the probability of
injury and death
the reasons for this bill are to prevent
a denial of bodily autonomy parental
rights
informed consent
and available therapeutics
thank you
thank you very much are there questions
for the representative
yes representative waltz
thank you
so i keep hearing this term natural
immunity thrown around in here and i
don't understand what it is because i
look at for example representative
oliver who would ordinarily be here he's
been
boosted he's head covered once and he's
got covert again
so he obviously doesn't have a natural
immunity to cover because he's gotten it
twice i'm trying to understand what
natural immunity means
uh
as a first responder
um we've been in this
particular pandemic from the start
um and what some of the uh
experience that came from that
not
as i've seen many different uh different
patients
and i've seen the likes of the
vaccinated and not vaccinated but i'd
like to
really hone in on that this isn't really
about
being anti-vaxxed
it has to do with the the mandate
but the conversation has to involve
vaccinations
so and to clarify i believe that you
the common cold for example
some folks can deal with it better than
others
there are need for medical interventions
for some people
but not all
and through my personal experience i
have seen that
but i can also follow up with some more
information
for you if you'd like thank you
as uh no for the committee here we do
have a department of health and human
services here
well
okay i didn't know if you wanted to ask
thank you rep santana do you have a
question uh yes uh thank you for coming
today and thank you for your work as an
emt
as an emt were you required to take
some
locations do require
um i'd rather not divulge
my personal medical information for that
for this conversation though i can't say
that we do know of locations departments
agencies that do require it yes
yes
so does nashua fire an em uh rescue emt
if you'd like i could follow up with the
specifics of those
and and what would be required at least
further questions
represent porter
thanks mr chair and thank you for taking
my question i think i'm going to follow
up a little bit on representative walt
so um
would natural natural immunity prevent
me from getting
hiv
thank you for the question
i believe the two are very different
um
and
you would have to
have a little more data on the uh
well on the person also i'm not certain
of any people that have
been exposed to it and somehow
further questions
representative mullen
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative lancer for taking my
question
um if i'm not mistaken uh i think i read
in the union leader this morning
that the new hampshire department of
public health has said that they have no
intention of seeking a covet 19 mandate
did you happen to
read that information or do you have any
information about that
thank you for your question
i did not know of that article or
information just prior to this meeting i
was notified of
some of the states
i believe you'll hear that very soon
their take on the mandates in general
if that helps
further questions
thank you very much
thank you again i'd like to invite
gary york
thank you chairman thank you members of
the committee
i i
could address the previous questions if
you would like or not
well maybe in your presentation you
could allude to it i will allude to it
thank you thank you
i heavily heavily support this bill for
uh prohibiting vaccination
for
superintendent for school districts
healthy
students of kindergarten through college
in our state
and across the country have much milder
symptoms to the variants of coba that
we've been exposed to so far
and now that we have omicron we have a
very mild
virus
and
people
adults through kids are suffering much
less than the previous variants
we should compare this as a
typical seasonal flu as far as symptoms
are go go this is the way that children
will handle these sort of things
and i don't see that we need to
add special
requirements for
a second
reason why we we should
support
this bill
is that the risk ratio
for
children
and covid
and especially omicron at this point
um
[Music]
it does not support an argument
for any kind of mandate
and i would refer to
the so-called holy grail of medical
ethics the nuremberg code
number four tenet of the code of ten
four of ten specifically states
the degree of risk to be taken should
never exceed that determined by the
humanitarian importance of the problem
there's no reason to have children
vaccinated
there was a bill yesterday that included
college kids and again
college age
young adults are
well adapted to handle the
exposure to covid and do very well
but there are some side effects
listed that we know are apparent uh for
for some of the vaccines including uh
myocarditis probably being the
number one
adverse
effect that's reported
and again you're talking about
inflammation of the heart and injury to
the heart where
the heart is not able to
repair itself
it has only so many cells to deal with
and if you
expose
or if you contact a disease of the of
the heart as a young person you'll carry
another point i'd like to make about
this
the
[Music]
covet vaccines have been shown to be
fairly ineffective for a long-term
durable
symptom
or
i should say it was designed to
lessen symptoms it was not designed to
prevent spread from
person to person and as one of the
representatives noted
she knew of someone who was multiply
vaccinated boostered and had covered
once twice etc so
um they're not as effective as we as we
the
the the
last
most important point i'd like to share
and i think it's good news uh good news
for the children and that is i've come
across some data from the cdc that
looked at
naturally occurring antibodies in
children in the 5 to 11 age group
and this was
determined from blood samples from all
across the country in from different
laboratories
and the data indicated that in november
december
in the 5 to 11 year old age group
of that population had
natural antibodies
now these are people that have not been
vaccinated injected
they are
so-called naive
in that they've had exposure to
covid
and
as children may not
have even been symptomatic
but
of that population had
natural antibodies
to
in other words
they
uh likely inhaled a
in this case a virus
their body
uh
all the defense mechanisms of the body
the b cells the t cells
all the other
defenders
found this
virus
and
went to work on preventing the
replication of the virus by producing
antibodies these are their own
antibodies
so so that's that's what is meant by
and i and i i don't want to spend time
on the
mrna vaccines
it's a bit more complicated
but
we can talk about it perhaps later but
the good news was 18 percent that was
november december 2020
six months later
they did the similar study
and the
number of the percent of
children in the 5 to 11 age group
the percent that had natural
covert antibodies
was
naturally occurring antibodies already
fast forward to today which is maybe
eight months later
and i think it's safe to assume that
the number of antibodies is well over 50
in that population given the
the spread of covid
so that's the good news
and i would like to just talk about a
minute about flu vaccines that we have a
yearly flu vaccine that we
may or may not take
but
experts in the medical field try to
anticipate and determine
which strain of the
influenza a influenza b influenza
whatever kovat whatever is going to be
coming next season
and
it's an estimate and it's not very good
the efficacy of these vaccines that we
take for the flu
are less than 50 percent
so if we consider omicron
a mild flu-like illness
already
the children
are well
protected more so than any vaccine for a
so i would just say uh for this bill i
support this bill
we don't need more mandates especially
for our children
uh for the safety of our children i
think the thing that to do is just to
leave them alone
take off their masks let them congregate
forget the shutdowns
leave them alone
and
let parents make decisions about any
vaccines that
thank you i'll take any questions thank
you very much dr uh representative
porter
thank you mr chair
doctor i didn't hear you when you
introduced yourself and told us where
you were from oh i'm sorry hopkinson new
hampshire okay thank you and
a follow-up
are people dying from omicron
it's very rare to find
any evidence of this being a
dangerous
thing about children and adults i'm
talking about why are the hospitals
having deaths then if omicron is not
um
i don't have the data for that typically
the people that are hospitalized have uh
what's called co-morbidities they have
underlying
conditions that would predispose them to
be
sick
but
healthy chill for the most part healthy
children and the most of our school
children are healthy
are going to do
uh well if they
represent cordelia do you have a
question
we don't have any i don't think we have
any
and i'm just recalling testimony from
yesterday from someone who looks at
[Music]
vaccine
information
and again this is not my testimony but
she held up um
a placard that showed how many people
have died how many children have died
from covid and that was a zero
and
that's i i won't say any more about that
thank you mr chairman and thank you
doctor for being here
do you know if any of the vaccines
have received
and i'm talking about use for children
have received fda approval beyond
emergency use
representative tanner
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
um
i actually have two parts this question
the first one is
do children who have that are infected
with covid
not from the vaccine but from the
infection
it is known i do not know
i don't think so
but i won't say for sure okay well my
my understanding is that it's
found more in
children who have coveted infections
than it is in
children who have myocarditis from the
vaccine so
so you're saying that you're saying that
the myocarditis occurs more frequently
in the covet infections infection it may
it may
thank you
uh doctor i have a question uh we have a
number of vaccines
that are required for entry into school
public schools right
there are certain exceptions why should
this
vaccine
be placed amongst the requirements like
polio or why should it not be placed in
to that category of a required shot
well i think the risk
to
the population the patient population in
this case is children
the risk
is
less than the risk of side effects from
thank you
representative mullen
could you elaborate on that thank you
very much mr chair
thank you doctor for taking my question
could you elaborate on that a little bit
i'm not sure that i understand um
i definitely remember being five years
old and standing in line for my polio
vaccine so uh
i think representative ladd's question
if we could sort of
ferret out a deeper answer to that
of the vaccines that are currently
what would make it okay for us to
require those
and
why would we or would we not put covid
well i guess i again i spoke to the
the resemblance to a flu-like illness i
mean i i would we
should we
include
annual flu vaccines for children i guess
that's
i'm looking at it as that it would be
similar to that
symptoms and
uh symptoms of covet and
or
symptoms of coed you know i'm saying
omicron with our current uh variant are
similar to a seasonal flu so
i don't think it's reasonable to expect
that kids would get a reason a
so may i follow up to where
representative and i are asking similar
questions so a polio vaccine
is the polio vaccine that i got
back in the
i hate to say it 1950s
uh the same now as it was then
and would a
covid vaccine
given today
be the same i don't want to say the same
number of years but many many many years
from now
so is is there a
a relationship between why
we do have polio shots
and then why it may not be wise to have
something such as we're talking about i
think i think i understand your question
polio is polio and
covid
deals with mutations of the virus and so
now scientists are trying to determine
should we have an omicron specific
vaccine for the current
trend
and they've developed
a
omicron specific vaccine
that
may or may not work as well as the
vaccine that we originally had
there are some studies in primates that
suggest that the omicron specific
vaccine developed for omicron
performs
less less effectively than the original
eua vaccine
so i think you're going to be looking at
a
yearly
yearly vaccination schedule for our kids
if that's something that would be
approved for something like covet just
as we would for influenza it's a
different recipe i think that answers my
question uh thank you uh representative
walton and representative ellison
thank you
doctor isn't it true that many vaccines
are given not just to protect the person
receiving the vaccine but to protect the
population that they come in touch with
that may be vulnerable and can't be
vaccinated
that argument has been used
a lot especially for the current
situation but my understanding that a
vaccine
is taken to protect the individual
and if we take the example of
well little john little johnny and
little susie have to get a vaccine for
grammy and grandpa
um
not really graham and grandpa need to
get a vaccine if they think it works
that's the way i see it
um have you seen the data that suggests
for example that grandparents get
vaccinated again against whooping cough
to protect their newborn grandchildren
that again that's one generation being
vaccinated to protect another generation
have you seen that in your medical work
um i i
i would just say that
as a physician my specialty is i'm not a
clinician i'm a pathologist
i worked
as a medical director for a laboratory
hospital laboratory so um and i can't
really i've heard of that i have heard
of that especially for
some people in my age who have
grandchildren who's whose parents are
insisting that they get
some such
vaccine that you're referring to
one more question sure um so
i want to make sure i heard you
correctly i thought i heard you say that
in the vast majority of cases
myocarditis causes permanent heart
damage yet everything i've read and even
looking up here suggests quite the
opposite that the vast majority of the
cases of myocarditis resolve themselves
with no long-term damage and it's really
only a small number of myocarditis cases
that actually cause any long-term damage
did i misunderstand what you were saying
if you're repeating what i said and i
still believe that it does cause
long-term damage and it increases the um
the lifespan of
people who have myocarditis they have a
shortened lifespan on
average
representative ellison
thank you mr chair thank you doctor for
taking my question
uh i i think at this point we're down to
about eight deaths a day
in terms of covet in the state and
that's dropping as it should
do you have a number for how many people
a day are dying from the flu in new
hampshire
i do not
thank you
representative porter then
representative whitcock
thank you mr chair so um
and thank you again doctor for for
indulging me
so if i am a child that can't get
vaccinated
i'm fragile for one reason or another
you don't
and i would need to be protected
because those around me were vaccinated
that would be a way that would protect
me i'm not the grandmother i'm another
kid in your class that's got cancer or
whatever can't get the vaccine wouldn't
that be a reason why we might want to
vaccinate children so that they can the
other the child that can't receive a
vaccine is protected
it might be a reasonable theoretical
reason to do it but
we've all seen that the vaccines are not
as effective as they
represented woodcock thank you chairman
don't feel bad you're not the first one
today thank you um
i appreciate you taking my question the
representative to introduce the bill
i i think i quote him correctly said the
conversation is really not about
anti-facts it's about mandates but this
facts of the mandate
um and as you went through your
testimony you indicated that um
you use the same word you said your
concern was this shouldn't be mandated
it should be left to the parent
um
during the last multiple months way too
many months
we've heard from the governor and from
dr chen and particularly the governor
saying all this should be local it
should be the local districts local
schools
and all these mayonnaise vaccinations
because every district is differently
it's different uh and the demographics
of it
you understand that so my my concern is
then if in fact we put this law in place
heavenway perhaps restricted to look at
the local districts or local school
areas of see from
responding and and two
um haven't we just done what we didn't
want to do which is put out a mandate
thank you chairman yes thank you for the
this bill actually prohibits prohibits a
mandate so um
parents still have the right to have
their children vaccinated
for this particular bill in question so
i don't think that would interfere with
that i think parents
i feel should be involved in that
did that answer your question
um
yeah that's fine thank you chairmanline
you're welcome uh represent cordelie
thank you
i've read recently that
one of the vaccine companies i believe
it is is testing the vaccine on children
age five and lower even to six-month-old
babies
do you have any thoughts on giving one
of these vaccines to a a one-year-old or
younger
it scares me
especially with the type of
vaccine technology that's being used
today
i wouldn't i wouldn't
approve it for my children if they were
of age to be getting that now or my
grandchildren
are there further questions yes
representation
uh thank you mr mcfair thank you for
taking the question would you say that
um because we had such short amount of
time
at this these vaccines have been out
that we're actually maybe experimenting
on our kids by giving them this vaccine
i would definitely say so i think the uh
the rollout of these vaccines came up
very fast we were originally told that
it would be a couple years
and
the original message was that we have no
treatment for this
but
i'll throw i'll throw you a bone of hope
and say a vaccine and a vaccine is the
only way to get you out of this mess
and we all held on to that we we had a
lot of fear at the beginning all of us
including myself including me
had a lot of fear
it was unfounded
but
the vaccines surprisingly came out in
about a year i think it was
and people were lining up left and right
so yeah there's a lot of safety data out
unfortunately it's not as good as we had
hoped but we have the vares system which
is the vaccine adverse
effect reporting system
which is
thought to be
very underreported
and
breaking news hopefully soon will be
evidence from the department of defense
which is
some whistleblowers have found some very
damning
evidence that
the vaccine injuries in this group of
people that is healthy young adults
has shown marked increase in
side effects over
the past five-year period before covid
uh we'll wait for that study to come out
and
hopefully it will come out and not cover
it up
follow-up
yes you may
do you think uh therapeutics have been
suppressed because of the vaccine
that's exactly why the eua authorization
was allowed to be
come through anyway thank you
because the only reason for the eua is
because
any chance at therapeutic therapeutic
interventions
including protocols by
numerous groups across the country
we're having success with
vitamin i ivermectin and that was
lambasted persecuted
and
uh thrown under the bus
and that's why the eua was allowed to
stay alive
because there was no reasonable
alternative to treatment at the time
thank you representative whitcock thank
you thank you charlotte uh talk to just
one more i just you caught me by
surprise and i just want to make sure i
heard you correctly you said that you
as we got the covered vaccine in the
colburn incident that you you the fear
was misplaced i think that's how you
framed it unfounded yeah unfounded okay
so you don't believe that's a founded
fear
oh that's a real good cause for fear for
sure but
if the u.s were to evaluate the data
of
people dying of covid
and not with kovid
i would suspect
like italy
did with their ministry of health
they reduced their
number of
people dying from covid from the
original numbers
by over 90 percent
so if you believe
that
if we were correct
our data that tell us that
it was more than 800 000 people have
died from covid
but to reevaluate that and to actually
classify it as people who died of covid
and not with covid with being testing
positive
and for sure
these people most of these people were
elderly had many comorbidities
health concerns
so um
[Music]
when i say unfounded
i'm i'm referring to that very statistic
that we all were hearing day in day out
thank you i i appreciate if i may i
appreciate the the response i just i
still find uh
by manipulating the way we
go back and look at the disaggregated
that data um
regardless of that we know that 800 000
died and had some impact because of
covet
thank you
representative waltz
yes thank you so are you telling me that
there are tens of thousands of doctors
across this country that have lied on
death certificates when they said that
i i'm not aware of the data and how it's
collected but if you if you have a death
certificate and
coven 19 is on the death certificate
that will be
a data point that
was likely collected for this number
that we're seeing
and if you had covid
it may have contributed
to your death
but
by having
things like obesity diabetes
asthma pulmonary disease
this may have been a contributing
follow-up factor and when doctors fill
out death certificates
don't they usually note that if there
were multiple things involved in the
death
indeed that they do
so if we have 900 000 people who were
said that they died of covid
not that they died of heart disease and
happened to have coveted but they died
of covid
are you suggesting that tens of
thousands of doctors are lying when they
i guess i'm not sure what you mean by
yeah not being truthful and what they
i i can't speak to physicians filling
out reports like that i'm sorry
i understand that but given that we have
900 000 people who are documented
undocumented to have died of covet these
are the people that we have documented
not people who just died at home without
documentation but documented cases
and i'm wondering
why that's not a valid number why you
question that number that we've got all
these people that have documented the
cause of death and you're suggesting
that that's not valid i'm trying to
understand your thinking here because
you're a doctor i trust doctors i trust
that doctors tell the truth you have to
take an oath i'm a lawyer i have to take
an oath we have to tell the truth and
what we do
so i'm very confused as to how you can
possibly say when there's nine hundred
thousand documented cases of covert
death but that's not what really
happened in this country
i guess i'm not trying to refute the
number i'm just i'm just trying to
separate
um
died of copied or
died with coped that's all i'm trying to
separate
further questions represent mullen
thank you mr chair and thank you dr york
for taking another question uh so the
difference between dying with covet and
of covid
if
i have uh diabetes
and i contract covid
and i die
that's dying with covid
unless
i didn't have diabetes or
if i had diabetes and i
didn't get covid and i didn't die
i mean are we
is this not a semantics issue
it is a semantic issue yes yes and my my
argument is that
the population uh the vast majority of
the population is in the elderly age
group with multiple
comorbidities
thank you very much are there any
further questions yes one more thank you
mr chair um do we have the numbers of
people before covert the average amount
of people who died a day
and can we compare that to like the
average amount of people who are dying
now
with including covet and then
perhaps figure out
uh how much of them or how much of an
covert yeah i mean that's a complicated
calculation for sure um
i think there was a insurance group uh
in the western u.s that recently
indicated that there was a 40 increase
in all costs more
alcohol all cause mortality
that was not attributed only to covid
so the
i don't have any numbers to share with
you but
certainly going forward
there are
there are data being collected for
looking as we go forward and then look
backward as to trends for
uh
all car all cause mortality
death and as it relates to coba death
not seeing any further questions thank
you very much doctor
good afternoon and thank you for uh
allowing me to speak representatives i
am um whoa i am speaking in support of
12 of um hb 1241
and there's a couple of reasons why i am
a mother of two children in the nashua
school district um i have given
testimony on other things before this is
something that i am very very passionate
about
um
i'm their mother
and
even with the existing vaccinations
there are pathways for exemptions and i
know that there have been a lot of
situations where people have mentioned
local control and not wanting to oversee
that as somebody coming from nashua i am
pleading with you please
make it so that these people cannot
mandate this vaccine for attendance to
public school
under the state law and federal law you
have to give people you have to give
children access to a free appropriate
public education especially students who
are in special education i have a child
with an iep and i'm struggling at this
point to even get a mask exemption
granted which was provided by his
pediatrician let alone having a vaccine
the issue that we're running into here
is choice
and that's something that i don't hear a
lot of people talk about it seems like
in that last part of this conversation
we've gone kind of totally off the rails
and the issue at hand with this bill is
prohibiting school districts from
forcing covid19 to be one of the
required vaccinations for attendance at
school now
i don't know if anyone is a parent or a
grandparent but there have been a lot of
correlations here that are not accurate
um if if your child is cr has chronic
ear infections and they tell you
that we have this vaccine that will stop
this we have no idea what it's going to
do 10 years from now and then while
they're testing it you find out that
because you have a female daughter it
may it may mess with her ovaries it may
discount the amount of eggs that she was
born with you may possibly
make your child infertile
you may sterilize your child
but we can't guarantee whether or not
this ear infection is going to go away
or it's not going to go away but you
have to get this so that other people
don't get this ear infection
because now it's communicable
it sounds ridiculous
for other people to be telling me what i
need to do with my children and their
health decisions in order to attend a
right
to public education is absolutely
astounding i'm not anti-vaxx or provacs
i'm pro-parental choice and guardian
choice
for you guys as a as a
communi as a committee
to stand behind 1241 that speaks volumes
why
because we're limiting the uh we're
limiting
the requirements for children
to have to get a vaccine that we don't
know the long-term effects if you are
allowing these districts to make this
coveted vaccine a mandatory vaccination
to attend public school who's going to
be held liable
for any vaccine injuries is it going to
be the school districts is it going to
be the state who's going to take out
that insurance policy
the issue here is you're taking
you're taking a situation where there's
a 99 or 99.999
survival rate for children and it is not
my responsibility and i'm going to be
the least popular person in this room
right now
probably if anybody's listening
it is not my responsibility to inoculate
my child to protect someone else
it just isn't
it is not my responsibility to lose my
rights
because someone else is afraid that they
might possibly get sick
we have been doing this for two years
it's enough
to force this mandate on a vaccine that
has now they're going through testing
and the nih again has quietly been
studying
the effects of this vaccine and it's i
mean we we could go down that rabbit
hole but we're not going to
the main concern is
don't tell me that i have to vaccinate
my children to attend public school so
that you feel protected if you have a
child who is immune compromised you have
absolutely every reason in the world to
keep your child protected
it is not my responsibility as a citizen
it is not my responsibility as a person
i live in the united states of america i
have a freedom of choice
and by not prohibiting this and by not
supporting 1241
you are again limiting our freedom of
choice
thank you i yield to questions i always
wanted to say that sorry
thank you are there any questions
from the committee
see none thank you very much for being
here
next we have
good afternoon my name is lori ordolano
i'm from nashua as well
my children are grown but i am very
concerned about this legislation um and
i i'm very concerned about we're doing
to legislate and
try to force vaccination onto a
population that doesn't need it so i
support hp 1241 to prohibit this
requirement
um i think we need to protect the rights
of parents and young adults to exercise
informed consent for medical decisions
particularly when they involve
experimental treatments
as we come out of this pandemic and peel
away at the fear messaging i'm concerned
that we're going to learn that medical
ethics ethical standards were
compromised for corporate profits and
how are parents supposed to effectively
safeguard the rights and their for their
children
when unvetted unsubstantiated data has
been harmonized into a message that
eliminates choice
it appears that scientific debate has
been eliminated
the absence of this debate on covet
treatment created a fear that focused us
on dying
if the real message of viable treatment
protocols vaccine injury and possible
death from vaccines were broadcast on
major media networks
information choice and knowledge
would have mitigated a lot of this fear
something is terribly wrong when the
government denies us this type of
information
anyone with a message that created
vaccine hesitancy
was reputationally dis destroyed experts
we could not get a balanced view
there are too many pandemic legislative
packages being pushed through right now
that have eliminated medical bioethics
thinking people and more importantly
parents and young adults
need to be able to ask why and how
questions
the active manipulation and management
of pandemic data is stunning
i think when history memorializes all of
this we're going to hold our heads in
disgust and recognize that three
generations of health have been
compromised
and there were a few things mentioned
about natural immunity that were brought
up here there's a couple things i'd like
to speak to
the big concern i have is that when all
of this started the doctors did not seem
at all interested in performing the
tests on the people coming in with covid
or before promoting um vaccinations to
see if they had natural immunity they
did not collect that kind of test data
they weren't interested in my neighbor
takes her dog to the vet and gets it
tightered to see if it has immunity so
it doesn't get vaccinated
and that's readily available they
weren't doing it for us for this
pandemic and i think that's how we could
look at natural immunity and understand
it
i know people who have had natural
immunity
for 18 months that have had coveted and
they get it checked every six months
so the number of deaths
when we talk about whether that number
is real what we're not talking about is
the fact that we failed to offer proper
treatment protocols early on
we restricted
off-label medications
cobit is an inflammatory disease and
we've known how to treat inflammation in
this country for 40 years
how did we miss the broad side of the
barn
because we had pharmaceutical companies
that were working on expensive new
developments that instead of costing
pennies for a dose cost a thousand or
two or three thousand dollars a dose and
we had to do it that way
they were forced
so those numbers
i think would have been a lot lower had
there been choices out there
myocarditis that was brought up while i
was sitting here listening to what are
the reports i googled on my phone i'm
always interested in data what is the
data say about myocarditis caused by
copin 19 infections i couldn't find any
data online
what it said is it wasn't really there
wasn't certainty that it was linked
you can find more data on myocarditis
with vaccination online but i couldn't
find the other so that's a problem
there's not a balanced view of data that
the concept and i'm going to be as
unpopular as the lady before me who
spoke that we need to inoculate all of
the children to protect
some other child that might have an
illness is just not fair or reasonable
i went to my board of aldermen chamber
two weeks ago and the masking debate was
running hot and heavy there's a lot of
people who want the mandate taken down
and one of the aldermen said hey i have
a two-year-old who's not vaccinated
it's your responsibility nashua the
entire city to keep your mask on for my
two-year-old
what they feel to realize is their
two-year-old is more at risk of dying in
a bicycle accident
than from covet
should we mandate that no child can ride
a bike
and for that matter all adults shouldn't
either because it would hurt the child's
feelings
we need to stop this
i am so opposed to this
mandating and regulations that are being
laid down on this pandemic
because i feel like we lost our minds
we rushed we went 100 miles an hour no
one put the brakes on to say wait a
minute let's take a look at this
and i think it's starting to roll out
these doctors that were shunned are now
being invited to europe to speak to you
know presidents and prime ministers
about you know what's really going on
with their data over there
okay
the united states not going to lead on
this anymore because i believe we really
sullied our reputation
and we're not going to be some
preeminent medical
group that is going to have the answers
when
something major happens
we're not gonna look we don't shine
bright through this
at all
and i i i at this point and i wore my
mask like my underwear i flipped and
believed in my mask three weeks before
anyone else did
i shed my mask in december after doing
more research
done
and while nashua has a mass mandate i
don't shop in nashua anymore although i
live there i don't i go to the
surrounding towns
lori
can i just interrupt you for a second
please we have just gotten a message
that we have somebody from uh health and
human services here and they have to
leave but they have a little bit of
information for us go ahead we can have
you come right back it's no problem i
i'd appreciate that thank you guys
we have some technical advice here that
um
we'd like to hear perfect from them
rogers morning my name is uh good
afternoon my name is abby rogers i'm the
legislative liaison for the division of
public health services and i really
appreciate the last person who testified
giving up her time for me to come in for
a minute i and thank you mr chair for
the accommodation um i wanted to just
i'm just here briefly to provide some
information
about hp 1241.
the way that the department reads the
bill is it would prohibit
individual school districts from
mandated the coven 19 vaccine currently
um
currently the school district says we
have
read the bill and reached out to the
department of justice does not currently
have that authority um so it would be
mandating something that uh prohibiting
something that they don't have the
authority to do right now and we just
wanted to point that out so under
141c20 uh the department the
commissioner of health and human
services um through rulemaking can add
uh conditions to uh the school uh
requirement for to attend school so we
just wanted to clarify that the
authorities under the commissioner of
health human services under 141 c20 and
currently
um on our outreach with the attorney
general's office that they they did say
that they um
school individual school districts do
not have the the authority to mandate
any vaccines um and
uh that's what i was here to provide
today is there any questions thank you
very much that's clarification
representative mullen
thank you very much uh mr chair and
thanks abby for coming in this afternoon
am i correct did i read something in the
paper this morning that says that the
public health offices have said that
they
there is no plan for mandating a vaccine
for school-age kids
uh that's correct we testified yesterday
on a bill in uh house hhs
we do not have any plans at this time to
mandate the covenant vaccine for
school-aged children if we were to do
that it would be
under
when the resources and the times the
time is right to do that
we don't feel that that's necessary at
yeah rep senator boehm and then
represent woodcock
thank you mr chairman thank you taking
the question so you said so what does
one do
if their school district is mandating it
what their resource that the people can
take since you said they do not have the
authority to do it
thank you for the question my
understanding is individual school
districts do not have the authority to
mandate vaccines
they can make recommendations about
masking and testing in schools but right
now they they don't have the authority
to do that so i i don't think a school
district would go ahead and try to do
that
but if a school district does what can
somebody do
to stop the school district from doing
it
well according to 141 rsa 141c only the
commissioner of health and human
services has that authority to add
school dis vaccines to school
recommendations for requirements for for
school
so it wouldn't be it would be against
okay uh are there any other questions
from uh the department
yes representative thank you very much
uh mr chair thank you very much for
joining us this afternoon um uh ms
rogers so are you saying then that this
um
hospital 1241 is not necessary
uh from the way that the department of
health and human services reads the bill
are there other questions of the
department
thank you very much abby appreciate it
accommodation
we're going to invite laurie back
i'll be super quick um i want to talk
about boards of health nashua is a big
city and we have a board of health that
has what i consider three pretty
qualified
people on it and that two are doctors
and one's a dentist
internal medicine pediatrician and a
dentist most boards of health for small
communities consists of the fire chief
our surrounding areas the fire chief
litchfield that used to be the building
inspector was the board of health person
too so a lot of small communities don't
have the expertise of a of a of a
talented board degreed in some level of
medicine the board of health in nashua
has been the most frustrating thing
to deal with for me
they don't answer questions
in the last four meetings they cancelled
public input twice
they have never held a form to allow
questions if you email them in and ask
them to put them on the agenda and
discuss them they're ignored if you want
to challenge some of the things that are
being stated like they're pushing
boosters for all children
why are we pushing a booster two
variants past now on children
you know what's the point of that
we had two hospital executives come in
at the last meeting
and state that based on what they're
seeing in our local hospitals
that those coming into i see those
coming into the hospital 50 it was a 50
50 split 50 had had the vaccination 50
percent didn't so when the board of
health said hey are you seeing all these
unvaccinated people filling hospital
beds both executives said no
it's equal
the second question was well are you
seeing a benefit
in the recovery and the level of
sickness for those who are boosted and
they said no it's negligible
so these boards of health are very ours
in nashua is so frustrating the minutes
came out from the last meeting in in
probably 125 point font the first header
on the minutes said no public comment
that shouldn't be the bolded comment of
your meeting
this has
we don't want to be talking about a
board of health or a health officer we
want to be talking about this bill okay
so this is why i think this bill is
important for nashua
because i don't think nashua will listen
to dhhs or if there's any level of
interpretation that's allowed in law
nashua will interpret it in their own
method and come up and say nope you know
what we have the right and we'll do it
it's been one of the most stringent
areas for closure 13 months of school
closure masking all year long with no
break at all
they take it to the extreme so to me
this bill is very important and i think
the vaccine served a purpose for the
older population from the get-go
this older population should have been
vaccinated the data showed that
but for the younger population i can't
see where it ever showed that and i'm
not even certain regardless of the bill
why we push that so much now thank you
thank you very much are there any
questions from the committee
have you done this card yet
hi i'm allison dyer i'm also from nashua
um
i think this bill is necessary and now
i'm slightly confused after abby spoke
because i thought this this bill was
necessary because
representative marsh put in 1633 to
require it through 141. so
to me as a parent
this is not political it's parental and
this is necessary to protect
um my rights as a parent and and my
directive to you know the what is it the
uh
the due process class where i direct the
education and upbringing of my child
that's in my direct care so
that that would be
that
um
i am
i'm a child of the 80s so i'm kind of
looking at this like you know how i came
up and and what what has changed now um
i'm not really sure what's different
about covet 19
um
that
as the lady before me spoke that we we
kind of all have just lost our minds i
mean i'm the the child of a nurse uh
she's been an icu nurse for 47 years i
myself work in healthcare on the
administrative side i'm confused by all
all of this
necessary push i was confused with the
the hb 1633 and because of hp
1633 i felt like 1241 is absolutely
necessary
um
as the mother to a seven-year-old i i
have thought the immune system since i
was a kid was a wonderful thing and i
know there's been some question about
you know natural immunity and things of
that nature but
um my child has never had
the traditional cova test without be pcr
and whatnot
but she has had a coping antibody test
she said two
and she's had two
in 13 months one after six months and
then another seven months later
and her code antibiotics has shown
reactive this entire time and if you all
check your emails i have sent you
13 months of reactive antibiotics for a
seven-year-old and i'm not even quite
sure when she actually was sick because
she has environmental allergies i
thought maybe it was an allergy cycle
but
i wanted to know
and my pediatrician said to me that i
was the first parent to ask
for an antibody test she wasn't even
quite sure how to order it
and that's sad to me because when i
think of
i mean i have a few friends who have
adopted children from other countries
and they come here those kids have no
medical history
when they get here we don't just
start inoculating them and giving them
immunizations we we take a whole picture
of that child we we you know we do lab
work we do scans we do all those types
of things for a reason
and then we make a vaccine schedule
based on what
that shows what the blood work shows
what the scans show all of that um we
don't want to just guess so
for me i wouldn't want to just guess and
and
as i think some other people have stated
too that the um
the fda advisory committee dr rubin
who also was the lead editor for new
england journal of medicine said we're
never going to learn how safe this
vaccine is until we start giving it that
doesn't give me a lot of confidence as a
parent as a parent who has been
tracking
the fact that my child is showing
reactive covet antibodies for 13 months
and i myself
i donate blood every year which is how i
found out i myself had coved um they
sent me my blood results in the mail and
said you covered i have copic antibodies
so i said oh this is a good thing to
track i'll do this little experiment on
myself um
and i have done that every six months i
have had a cove antibody titer pulled
and i still show reactive and i haven't
been sick and i understand that that is
not everyone's story that's not
everyone's case
but
i haven't been sick again and i haven't
given it to anybody that i'm aware of
and and neither has my child and
why this is good is because for for for
all of history until covet happened
we've kind of thrown that out the the
proverbial window of things that we we
used to trust in things like you know i
mean even the cdc website talks all the
time about the mmr and and and
chickenpox and things like that i had
chickenpox i didn't have the chickenpox
vaccine i understand that things like
you know uh the covet is different
like hiv is a retrovirus so like it's
not going to be the same type of thing
but
this is this bill is in response to
something that someone else in this
legislature is trying to do and it's
going to be the protection and again i
know i'm from nashua
and a couple people here are as well but
they're they're right
nashua whether it's the board of
education or the board of health or
whatever will find a way
to try to do this because that and they
they
feel that it's right i'm not really sure
what they feel or what they think but
you know
as a parent i i need
we're in a place now which is very sad
because earlier today we testified on
the the parents bill of rights
it's sad right now i'm in a place where
i need your help
as the legislative people to protect my
rights as a parent so that i can still
send my child to school
our own new hampshire vaccine schedule
as you all are aware of
it lists natural immunity as
in lieu of if you can prove through
laboratory results
that you have natural immunity then you
don't need this vaccine and you submit
that to your kid's school that's what my
parents did for me i i dug it out of the
cabinet the other day to look i said i i
did what did you put down what did you
write for me with chickenpox and it's
it's there she included my lab titer
test and i went to school and it was no
problem and
i'm sad to be here today
to ask you to just let us keep our
parental
ability with risk there must be choice
and right now i feel like we're
someone like my daughter is showing the
natural immunity for the length of time
that she is if if it ever wanes and you
know as someone who has worked in health
care uh
the flu
vaccine was was mandatory but had been
out and fda approved for seven years
we had seven years of data to look at
if in the future we get five
seven
ten years data set to look at for these
kids and we can see that the risk
benefit ratio is there
let's look back at it but right now i'm
asking you to support this because
if
1633 goes anywhere which i'm now like i
said i'm a little confused
as to what that means what abby said
then
we need this
and i'm asking for your help with that
so thank you thank you very much uh any
questions
thank you very much
do you have any more cards
good so we're going to close this
hearing
that was our last hearing for today and
this committee's going to go into we're
going to call the commissioner up and
get him over here now he was here
waiting for us
so i'll call him up so let's take about
a 15-minute break for him to walk over
from the ag building and
um
okay we're going to start here in about
hey
okay folks i know it's been a long day
but we're going to continue now
we're very fortunate to have the
commissioner of agriculture here
in marketing
and he's going to
speak to us a little bit about the we
have two bills this afternoon and he's
going to speak to 1164.
this is a bill revising the agriculture
and the classroom committee
um
a bill which i didn't know much about i
didn't know we had such an organization
before this bill came forward
and um
sean do you want to speak at all to it
first or i'm sure there might be a few
questions that come from i i would um so
first of all my sincere apologies
to the committee for missing
the original hearing on this i just had
every
things going in so many different
directions and i actually thought that
wednesday was tuesday so i showed up on
the hearing
uh i showed up for the hearing on
wednesday thinking it was tuesday
so that's what happened to me
and i apologize
well
you you should know me well enough
representative porter to believe that
all right
um so
the interesting thing here is that there
has been an agriculture in the classroom
committee
for many many years
and i don't understand the full history
but that has existed
as a separate
non-profit
organization
but within its charter they have the
governor making all these appointments
well of course you a non-profit can't
tell the governor to make appointments
and then a number of years ago
the state
ag in the classroom committee was formed
having governor making appointments
essentially
the same people were involved so if you
looked at their charge and you looked at
their membership they were identical
but
essentially
the two never met
so what i have done at this point with
the cooperation of the governor's office
was actually have the appointments made
under
what is the rsa number here
the appointments have been made for the
most part there's some corp some under
rsa 425 25
most of the appointments have been made
at least to the degree that the
organizations have existed or been
cooperative
so we've lined things up
but the problem is with the existing
board is they said well we
have to be
a non-profit
uh and for good reason because one of
the things that farm bureau
has been very gracious in doing as part
of their dues a dollar
from their dues goes to ag in the
classroom
and they also allow for additional
donations to be made through the farm
bureau membership
and so that have in other donations come
in and so having the ability to be a
non-profit
is very important to the actual
operation of ag in the classroom so
working with the atten attorney
general's office
and the existing ag in the classroom
committee we found a way
to
merge the two and finally have just one
organization
that accomplishes the goal of what the
state was looking for and for what the
nonprofit is looking for
some of the organizations that were
listed
were non-existent
there is one
mistake that ended up
in this bill
so if you have the numbered pages
it's line 28 of
essentially the first page
and it says a a representative of the
new hampshire plant growers association
the plant growers association nominally
exists but they don't actually have an
active membership and they're they exist
for some other reasons
but not as an active membership
what we would like to have put in the
place which is g
would be in place of the plant growers
association the new hampshire fruit
growers association they are active
participants
in this organization
so that is the only
change that i would ask you to make and
i
submit myself to
to any questions or criticisms that you
might have
well thank you very much uh sean and of
course
our first question always is
representative porter over there
hi are you actually calling on me
i thought
yes i will i will ask you a question so
is it usual that we have a non-profit
that's also a commission that has
commissioners
appointed by the governor is that a uh i
mean
it seems different to me than the other
commissions that i've known over been
part of
it is different yes yes it is but
the attorney general's office did find
another example to use so it's not this
would not be the only such such thing so
they're
a committee of of the state but they are
allowed to operate um in this manner as
an on a non-profit oh and i
i didn't mean to mention one thing
currently within the department of
agriculture budget there is an
appropriation
i
think it's at 15 or 16 000
a year
to the ag in the classroom committee
which was one of
the issues that i had once i figured out
that there was
um
there were these two separate
organizations
i felt technically i should be making
the org the donation or the
appropriation to the committee that
actually wasn't functioning yet for
as long as our records show we've been
making it to the other so that was part
of the issue as well
um
and so i said
to them need to make this change and
probably if we can't make this happen
then i probably shouldn't be supporting
the active organization because i don't
think that's legislative intent but
it's just been a mess and this seems to
be the only way to straighten out the
mess and accomplish everyone's goals
right so so it has funding and it also
accepts donations correct and and does
it have a budget and all that kind of
stuff it does and is that information
all like online somewhere for us to see
um i don't know about
the
i don't know about the budget i mean it
is public information but i don't think
that on the on the website and there is
an ag in the classroom website
um i don't think the budget information
is is is there
but they do do filings so
i haven't looked into that that detail
and certainly as a because i'm i'm a
member of both
both boards
represent tanner do you have your hand
up down there
thank you and thank you for taking my
question i was wondering how the goal of
this group and this committee
is different from the unh extension
service
um
thank you for the question
unh cooperative extension
provides education
to farmers really to people who are
actively
engaged in agriculture or to to
homeowners but the goal of this
organization is to get
children
interested and aware of what's going on
in agriculture
um at a young age
so
for instance there's the remick museum
which is one of the places i went went
to with ag in the classroom and they
they do these tours i've also been um to
deerfield
where it wasn't an ag in the classroom
per se but where they bring farm animals
into the schools and the kids learn
about them from from farmers so this is
strictly educational
in terms of
what farm animals are and what farming
is about versus cooperative education
cooperative extension which would teach
about plant diseases and how to properly
plant and help people with questions so
there really are two different two
totally different things
and hopefully you know the kids who get
an interest here would be interested in
youth organizations such as 4-h and ffa
so it's really to to grab their
attention at a very young age because
these are great school kids primarily
although the charge goes beyond that but
with the limited resources
it's more at a younger age represent
woodcock did you have your hand up i did
chairman thank you so much thank you
good afternoon thank you for taking my
question uh and in line 17 but you don't
you don't need to look i can tell you
what it says it just says you have an
education director when funding allows
is there currently an education director
and what are the funding for that level
um
part-time yeah um i don't know what what
her salary is right now but it is a
part-time position okay that is funded
through the monies coming in from
the state because there are educational
materials
that
we provide and there are things that the
committee provides um
but most of the money i think right now
that comes in
does go to
support the one person who's who's
getting paid there
to coordinate to set up the events and
okay it is a lot of work to get these
going on and obviously in the last
couple of years it's been uh difficult
to get districts to let
yes thank you thank you secretary i
wasn't questioning the needed positions
yeah i was questioning would because it
sounds important uh but i was
questioning when it said when funding
allowed i could see well about this year
next year that was my only concern it's
been consistent and it has been one
one individual for a number of years as
long as i can remember okay thank you
very much that's perfect thank you very
much thank you chairman i i notice on
page two of the bill
there's a
a part o on line 11. any additional
members appointed by the majority vote
of the committee so the committee can
expand itself if he wants is that
correct except to the degree
that if you go to
uh
where's the line it does say
up to 20. so if you add up
all of
all of the current authorized positions
there are four who are by virtue of
office
and then an additional 10
from various organizations so that would
only allow
six additional people to be to be
appointed by the committee you know i've
sort of gone back and forth on that on
my mind
um one of the things people have said is
well why have the the committee not make
the appointments
i i find those relationships to be a
little bit incestuous
being on a few where it's just
self-perpetuating and there's not
really a lot of opportunity for others
to come in so i think the process that
we use where
organizations make a nomination and the
governor looks at them
works well and i think by having another
six that the committee could put on
there are other people who may not
represent any of these areas and we do
have some now
to allow the committee to put those on
it's still
going to be a minimum of you know 14 to
six so i think it strikes a good balance
of of the concerns that others have had
represent like us
since this is something we really don't
know anything about
can you give us a number of examples um
of things that
the
people are doing you know what kind of
education etc so every year and and i
think this is around the third or fourth
grade level and i that they primarily
have been focusing on
so there are books that we purchase
for younger kids and they may be even
younger younger than that to get out
into the schools that are relative to
about agriculture and they provide those
books and other materials to to teachers
who are willing to participate and
obviously you can't get everybody
participating but we work very hard
to
and doe does take an active role in the
in the committee currently
so get the informations out into the
schools
set up as many of these field trips as
we can
um close to various districts where they
come in hopefully to active farms such
as the remick museum or anybody else
who's willing to host and get those kids
there and um
thank you very much
it really is about educating kids about
ag that's cool thank you
representative walt's going to ask you
uh
an attorney type question uh-oh i played
kate says
i'm sorry the 8 says the committee shall
be a not-for-profit voluntary
corporation under rsa 292 and she'll
possess all the general powers of a
non-for-profit corporation
can you tell me anyplace else in the
state that the state has a non-profit
corporation serving as a committee and
i i can't what i can tell you is i did
send this to the ag's office to say will
you please
write this language so that we can
function this way and they did and you
know i
not a lawyer i used to play one in the
legislature but
um
i still do yes
so i didn't look into this terribly
in depth because that didn't really
matter to me the goal was what mattered
here not how they got there i trusted
the ag's office to do what needed to be
done again the important part was to
reconcile
the fact that we have two separate
mirror organizations except that the one
that was established in 425.25
doesn't have the ability to function as
a non-profit
and so the one that is already
established long established as a
non-profit
needed to be able to continue in my my
belief
in order to get the state appropriation
in order to
be set up the way they even they
intended again going back to the fact
that they had the governor making all
these appointments and the governors
never made them so they weren't even
following their own guidelines i went in
one point and said okay there are only
two legal members of the committee
present
myself
and the representative of the department
of education
and so this brings that all together
allows the function to continue
in a unique way that i believe
serves everyone well but particularly
serves the children who we're trying to
reach in the appropriate manner
so this isn't something i dreamed up in
terms of the language this is directly
from the ag mr i actually have a
question for you can we get somebody
from the ag's in office in to explain
this because it's i don't know if any
place else is state government we have a
non-profit corporation and i'm trying to
understand
why we're expanding government into a
non-profit corporation it just
seems like a strange setup to me
i don't know if jonathan would want to
come up here or not you think
uh we could try they'd be great thank
i i've got a question for you do you
um have you ever given any consideration
to involving the state fair association
seen they work with 4-h and all that
other um and be a good way to integrate
some of the purpose and responsibilities
of this into grades three and four
i have not
given that any any thought
representative ladd um certainly not
opposed to it it's been very difficult
to get
people involved and you and i know very
well on our on the bill that you
sponsored we didn't even have anybody
show up for that hearing um so i'm not
sure how active the state fair
association is i am and
you know unrelated to this i am working
to make sure that if the
uh your bill uh makes it through the
house next week and goes to a second
committee that there will be
representatives from the state fair
association but
um
it is difficult sometimes to get
organizations involved in things outside
of their their scope
so
i don't have a good answer for you on
that
representative
thanks thanks very much mr chair and
sean it's great to see you good to see
you so thanks for being with us this
afternoon
um when when when you were addressing um
representative walsh's um question about
why a um why
why essentially a government
based nonprofit as opposed to a 501 c 3
type non-profit and i think i heard you
say so it could um it could it could
basically take state appropriations
well yes i think because we could leave
it alone and just
eliminate rsa uh 425 25
and then i suppose the appropriation
could still be made
to this organization they grew through
like the farm bureau well
currently um
the
ffa receives a donation
from from the state same amount of money
so ag in the classroom and the ffa to
their association get the same
the same level of funding yeah
but because this exists in rsa25 you
know 425 it didn't seem as though this
approach the appropriation that has been
going to
the shadow organization that was really
proper sure
and i do think because you know
we should have
the commissioner of education and the
commissioner of agriculture on this
again it would be
do you how do you
tell a non-profit
that they're going to put certain people
on their board
and how does that happen and and i think
the structure of who's on the board is
good
and i think the fact that it's not as i
said incestuous
is good so i i i just i think it makes a
lot of sense even though it may be a
little bit different but it's
essentially how it's been
uh organized just
not
not in a way that really meets
checks off all the boxes that it should
and a follow-up on that not to hold you
to the dollars and cents
but um you know uh bigger than a bread
box smaller than an elephant um what do
you do do you remember when and how much
the last state appropriation was to this
program
i think it had been
i think i'm i think we're at 15 000 this
year going to 16 000 and i think it had
been at
13 or 14 for a number of years there had
not been any increase in the
appropriation for many so it's a very
nominal statement appropriations yes
yeah and um and then finally just a
comment because we've had a whole day of
these hearings uh the um the
the um
committee certainly wouldn't be
promoting things like organic farming or
discriminating against roundup and stuff
like that no no the committee is
strictly
it's not a question
committee is truly just about educate
educating about what farming is really
right no no
and in all serious i come from uh from
an agriculture from a far um an
agricultural family that uh that that
did do organic uh farming so thanks
representative porter mr chair thank you
and you shocked me so much before you
called on me that i lost the answer that
you'd given me uh representative
you started out by saying there were two
shadows the two
the other one was there was nobody on it
and it it was not functioning at all or
did you join the church yeah no
the one that was established under 42 25
was not functioning at all were there
any members or anything no the governor
had never made an appointment because
apparently no commissioner of
agriculture had ever asked him to and on
the other hand the the
bylaws of the one that was functioning
also called for the governor to make
those appointments but you can't have a
private organization telling the
governor what to do
and so what they had been doing was
reaching out to members of those
organizations
in most cases but not all
and appointing somebody on their own
so it was a violation of their own
bylaws but their own bylaws made no
legal sense
so
i was scratching my head for a long
while trying to figure out what i was
going to do with this mess
okay
are there any other questions of the
commissioner
yes
well thank you very much sean appreciate
hey so um i don't think there is there
any more discussion on this particular
bill
it's not an early bill so we have a
hermie
they're not they're not here no we we'd
have to we'd have to get them
we got some time yeah and we
across the street we'll have to yeah
yeah
i'll get together with you then yeah i
think there were
that'd be good
okay so what we'll do is we'll stop this
work session on this particular bill and
then move over to the
second bill which we had 1657
establishing a new farm to school
reimbursement program does everybody
and we have some technical support here
i see mackenzie snow i see diana fenton
and others from
d.o.e
so
welcome mackenzie and company
establishing
thank you and and we're here to respond
to any technical questions that the
committee might have again my name is
mckinsey snow division director of
learning we're going to get that a
little closer to you mackenzie
again my name is mackenzie snow division
director of learner support
and kelly rambo administrator for the
program of nutrition services
okay so we're dealing with a bill here
which deals with farm to school
reimbursement it's a program and there's
different tiers
does anybody have some questions for the
everybody's trying to catch up i know
i just like the department of ed to feel
welcome in our committee room all the
time uh thank you for taking my question
obviously you guys have looked at the
bill
um care to share some thoughts on
what what your impression is of the bill
thank you for the question
representative mullen so we of course do
not have stances on bills but we're
happy to respond to technical requests
from the committee we
previously provided testimony on this
bill related to the implementation
considerations specifically for the new
hampshire department of education and
school districts and implementing this
proposal
go ahead
thank you
with regards to the implementation of
the program could you remind us um what
you
shared with us when you were part of the
full day of madness and uh
sort of highlight
if if you have concerns what those
sure
so currently we have
480 schools that are in the national
school lunch program so all of those
schools would have the opportunity to
provide in this program
and that would take an additional one to
two
program assistance to implement on the
back end of
claiming
tech support anything along those lines
as far as the state is concerned for
that
representative woodcock
thank you
good afternoon ladies thank you for
coming back um for the layman here can
you just give me the the
easy layman summary of how the money is
distributed from the school how does the
school district actually get the money
sure for thank you
for claiming purposes yes please it's a
reimbursable program so they serve
the meals in this case it would be
the food that's purchased and then it
would be a reimbursable a reimbursement
based off of the claims or the amount
is there a maximum limit to that i know
you have x amount in the budget is there
maximum limit for reimbursement so it's
not it's not pre-approved
as for this bill it's stated here that
it will cover twelve hundred dollars
total okay thank you thank you chairman
there is reimbursement uh based on
whether you're in tier one
or tier two thirty three percent sixteen
percent
um
does the rim is the reimbursement
contingent upon usda approval
are they involved with this or we just
go to any farm or any you know and just
bring that stuff into the schools and
you get us you know reimbursed for the
cost at 33 or 16 percent
as it states in this bill proposed that
this would be state
state funded so the usda would not have
a
um a point to to say in that so those
logistics would need to be figured out
as far as tier one or tier two um i know
there's a little bit of specifics in
here on tier one or tier two but there
would be a lot more
in-depth conversations that would need
to be had on that topic
and can you explain tier one a little
bit better to me um tier one being our
state tier two being outside in the
periphery states around us their
contingent to us or abutting us
is a product
that's being produced in tier 1
territory
but owned by
tier 2
company
what kind of break are they going to get
are they going to get the tier 2 break
or the tier 1 break for reimbursement in
the schools
so
the legislation specifically uh
requests that the new hampshire
department of education the state board
of education promulgate rules on
providers and specific eligible foods so
that would likely be a technical
question that needed to be borne out in
those rules
so
my pop so it's not defined in this
statutory language
a specific question where a
farm might be located in the state of
new hampshire but was owned by a company
in a tier two state no that specific
question is not conceived of in the
legislation and likely would be
something that we would need to rule
make on
and i'll just one last one here so
milk that's and i'm talking about my
community hatchling dairy is unto
haverhill
everything's you know
fed there
born there
packaged there and sold from there
but then we have other products which
are new hampshire products that are
leaving our state in agrimark or
somewhere else and they're leaving for
you know being put together and
everything outside our state
that's
so whether that's tier one or tier two
that's not defined in this bill it's
something you'd have to do through rules
is that how i understand that
yes that specific scenario in which um
there it could be classified as either
tier one or tier two uh based on
production versus ownership would be a
question that we would need to address
in roles
okay
represent boom
thank you mr chairman thank you for
coming i um
can't school districts now contract with
yes they absolutely can and there's some
and then sorry to to further clarify
your prior question chairman lad it
specifically indicates
the
place of origin of the food
but we would have to develop processes
and procedures for the self-attestation
of the producer for the place of origin
so we we would expect in the development
of those processes and procedures uh
whether or not the interpretation was
significant enough to require rule
making or could be accomplished in
guidance and technical assistance would
be something we would have to get into
in the weeds of implementation
yes i'd be concerned about the raw
material that came come from the state
but it goes over there it's packaged in
the form of a food
with a lot of other products blended in
with it
and that and that raises another
important question that
many of our
food service programs and schools do not
work with raw materials at this time or
do not work with raw materials
to a significant degree so that would
also require significant training for
the food service providers and
significant additional time on meal
preparation and we noted that in the
local expenditures but again those costs
were indeterminable by the agency
represent luna thanks very much mr chair
thanks very much for your technical um
uh support this afternoon
um so um so following on um chair ladd's
questions with respect to um
the clarity in the bill and rulemaking
under 541a
um uh do you
would it be reasonable
to uh to make certain rules as like the
ones you've you've discussed um
under 541a without having it spelled out
in black and white in the bill
and um and would it also be uh be
possible
for the um
for the department to generate a list of
approved suppliers so that food service
directors
in these schools don't need to
an appropriate tier one or tier two
supplier but can actually sort of uh
pick through the list make it easy from
the department
and um and uh uh
seek out those uh those products from
those suppliers and then seek
the
percentage reimbursement of the cost
from the department
thank you for the question i think
perhaps our greatest concern around rule
making on the specifications and
qualifications of eligible food and then
uh
creating a list of pre-approved
providers would be that we don't have
the current in-house expertise to do so
and that's again why we made it explicit
that we would need
an additional two new program
specialists likely to uh implement a
program similar to the size of the
national school lunch program on which
we have about three sometimes four staff
working
on that yes so thanks so
you know in in in some ways i don't see
this
all that different from a uh
from from the department standpoint with
to the let's say the learn everywhere
program where the department was vetting
and put compiling a list of
of service providers for that did did
putting that list together require how
many additional staff did that require
from the department
so so
that program is currently implemented
with existing staff but that has been an
exploration around
additional staff capacity but we do have
the in-house capacity to
vet
education service providers we are the
department of education we do not have
the in-house capacity to vet food
service providers and vendors
and that would likely be expertise that
we would need to develop
follow up on that because i want to make
it really clear that that i understand
that you're the department of it with
the department of education but a lot of
the learn everywhere providers are not
schools their businesses
their their manufacturing facilities
their sports complexes there are a lot
of things that are outside of what i
would call the the school environment so
i guess my question is
how did the department develop the
expertise to work with um or to real
understand and be able to vet
um an educational curriculum when it uh
when it when it's being delivered
through uh through non-um
you know through through a manufacturer
and engineering company or sports um
complex
thank you for the question so uh and i
was
again stated that it was related to the
approval of education service providers
we all know that education does not only
happen in a classroom setting so the
evaluation of a multitude of different
types of educational environments was
represent woodcock
thank you chairmanlet um
i have another question
uh on
in the school district of for example in
a scenario of
five schools
under that i'm trying to read school and
school districts is each is each school
within that school district
eligible for a maximum with 1200 dollars
it specifically states school per school
per year but that raises an important
question because we do see throughout
the proposal the term sau school
district or lea and school potentially
used interchangeably so we would seek
additional clarification on the intent
could you repeat the last sentence
so we would seek additional
clarification on the intent of whether
sau was meant school district or lea was
meant or school was meant okay thank you
very much chairman you're welcome uh
mackenzie i note that there is a six
hundred thousand dollar appropriation in
fy 23 for this
bill
if i were to ask the department and i've
done it several years back with the
prior commissioner
is this a priority of the department
we're looking at
nurse coordinator positions we're
looking position we're looking at
various folks expanding curriculum maybe
with personal finance literacy that
means more training and
support people there
is would this if stacked up against all
the other requests and your priorities
over there where would this stack up in
terms of appropriating additional
dollars for comfort
be placed on that priority scale
thank you for the question
whatever the legislature enacts is a
priority for the agency to administer
you're very good at that that's the same
answer i used to get from uh virginia
berry and you know we could never get uh
defined answers what is the priority
yet we come up with some legislation
like a nurse coordinator position or
whatever it might be
or a counselor position and on it goes
down the list
and well i'm not going to go there we
don't have a voucher program we have an
efa program it's not a voucher at any
rate so i i i think it's incumbent upon
the department to start you know tone up
the line here and give us some
priorities so what you see as you need
over there whether it's a new system to
run your budgets with or
or technology what have you um you know
we can take our shots
but you know is that the wisest way to
spend money i don't think so
thank you for the guidance i can state
that um
we are here to provide technical
assistance to my knowledge we were not
actively involved in the drafting of
this proposal um so so that would
provide an indication to the extent to
which it was
between the lines thanks
representative tanner
thank you um out of the 480 schools in
the lunch program how many are charter
schools
there's
137 i believe charter schools in in that
but i can get you a a definite number
so that's that's that have a a lunch
program
137 out of the 480.
yes but i can get you a definite um
number on that okay and are there
other private schools academies or
religious schools
that we're now sending students to that
um yes and i can get you that number as
well
and and they're getting reimbursed
through the um
through the lunch program
yes we do have some schools that um
participate through other through an siu
and get food through that program yes
okay thank you
representative mullen
i just can't stay off of this topic mr
chairman thank you
um
when you read the bill uh
mackenzie
you read it as a voluntary thing that
schools would opt in or
opt-in and then ultimately would have
the freedom to opt out if they chose to
at any point in time am i correct in
that
yes we do not interpret the legislative
proposal to require participation um and
it's only eligible for those schools
participating within us in slp currently
uh just a quick follow-up um
yeah because we we've gotten
a tremendous amount of email from
various communities that have
farmers farmers markets whatever in
support of this
so um would you believe that the bill's
author is sitting behind you in the
audience and if you should in fact need
any
follow-up information or to discuss any
language i'm sure she would be willing
when do you think you can get this going
the effective date is july 1 2022.
so that's another piece of significant
technical assistance we had previously
shared
it takes significant time to
have the supply side respond to this to
identify eligible vendors
to learn how to process raw foods
so we do not believe that we could
successfully implement this bill
okay so are you saying that the date
needs to be pushed out further
do you what do you think like another
fiscal year beyond that or july 1 2023
or january 1 2023 july 1 2020 24
or whatever
i think to effectively implement this
program to its full capability should be
at least until july
uh are there other questions from the
it's going on four o'clock almost here
big question to you yeah so on the uh
the two bills that that we've just
discussed in the in the full committee
work session
um we looking to push off the execs on
those
certainly the first one 1164 pending doj
well 1657 can't be pushed off that's an
early bill right all right so 1164 we'd
push that that could be pushed that's
right
but
1657 we will be
probably addressing tomorrow right and
so that that goes where after this
i don't know we have a prior speaker
here maybe he could tell us where his
guess is that a bill like this would go
to
appropriating the money from where
well but ways and means or finance i
don't know
well finance appropriates probably
finance
ways to meet where you're going to get
well that's a fine that's a
mary beth do you can you weigh in on
yeah it sounds like it's a long shot
yeah
yeah yeah
okay well thank you very much are there
any more questions for the department
sean do you have anything else to add to
and you'd think you'd think by now i
would have learned sometimes it's best
to keep my mouth shut but
um i do want to just speak to some of
the
the practicality or lack thereof of what
i'm what i'm seeing here
um
i think there are very few commodities
that new hampshire farmers could provide
consistently for school districts
during the year i think you have to to
realize
that because of the the low amount of
money that's being appropriated here per
school district
if school districts were expected to
set up
purchasing
for some commodities for a partial
year
and have to go someplace else you're
probably not going to have
a lot of participation
milk is probably the only thing that a
few
farms could supply consistently
throughout the year and i
you know i think the idea is nice for
new hampshire farmers
um i would
suspect for something like this to work
because this is so broad and twelve
hundred dollars is so little i can tell
you in hudson which is probably the
ninth or tenth largest district in the
state there are seven schools
that's seventy two hundred dollars a
year i can't believe for a moment that
the school district would put the time
um into this that it would take to
implement it for seventy two hundred
dollars that something like this i think
there would need to be a pilot program
you would need
a school district that was willing
to do this
and see if it was practical and how how
many people
could participate in the state because i
think you spread this out to where it's
like three dollars a student
spread out all over the state i think is
a practical matter for the farming
community
it's a great idea i would like to see
more involvement
but i think this
doesn't is is going to be a total
disappointment if you attempt to
implement it in this manner
thank you very much
uh anything else for the commissioner i
think it's good advice
i think that's sound advice thank you
okay
so we are done this work session i
appreciate the department and the
commissioner for coming over this
afternoon we do have a handout that the
representative from bedford is passing
out to everybody
representative porter
mr chair i know that you have received
we all have received an email from
anies jasmine who's works with the world
affairs council requesting
a member of the committee to be part of
a panel
discussing with with other with people
from other parts of the world
i just wanted to let you know that when
i was
acting as the legislative co-chair of
the youth advisory council we quite
often met with
representatives from other countries
through the world affairs council and
it's a very worthwhile and uh honorable
program
and if anybody feels that they could
participate in it
i think you would find you you learn as
well as uh as teach so i just wanted to
put a good word in when do they meet i
know when i was on youth advisory
council years ago with uh
folks out of uh i think she has a piano
that's sunday's we met no no no no no
the world affairs council is not the
youth advisory wow she has a she has a
panel that's being set up for some time
in march with a group of um educators
from around the world and they
specifically if you read her email
they're specifically looking for um
us to share with them
how we helped
um
implement
remote learning and and
um that kind of thing in the united
states and it's a
i she invited uh commissioner edelbach
edelbach blood edible
okay i say his name
ed ed a blue
okay i'm sorry it's long day it's a long
day yes anyway um but anyway he's part
of the panel and she's looking for some
somebody from the education committee or
two to be part of it as well as well as
a school board member from the state and
other people uh superintendent that sort
of panel so look in your emails for the
world affairs council and if anybody's
willing to work with her on that i know
you will find it um
edifying and rewarding
if i can just add to that i've probably
been on a dozen panels for them over the
years and i find it really rewarding as
they always have a really interesting
group sponsored by the state department
and the state department sends them to
my half dozen places around the country
new hampshire is one of them and it's
just it's a great group and as i say
it's usually a whole group that the
state department has put together and
sent around the country
kids in the youth advisory
always love it after they've met with
these other young people from around the
world
they just learn and ask questions and it
but this would be a chance for us
they're not looking for young people
with this they're looking for people who
are knowledgeable about education in the
state of new hampshire so just throwing
out a
courage thank you very much people that
are interested uh why don't you let me
know and then i will coordinate with
jasmine who's the person that is
coordinating it uh mr chair if i could
speak before you lose any more of your
members over there regarding the handout
that uh i just gave to you
uh this is a little homework assignment
from me i found the article fascinating
it came from the boston globe and it was
written by the chair of the derry school
board
so
it seemed to be exceptionally pertinent
and timely information given the fact
that we've been sort of
knocking around this idea of
public
participation and the role of school
boards and
just because
i checked a little bit on the
nature of these chairperson of the
school board in derry because i thought
please don't let this be a whining
democrat please don't let this be uh
right
so so i i just want you to know that i
uh
am not forcing you into reading anything
that i don't think you'll be interested
in
i believe that you would have a lot
ideologically uh in common with the
chairperson of the derry school board
and i would ask that you read it and if
there is any interest for fruitful
discussion later on perhaps we could
discuss it as part of a
either our exact session on public
participation or
maybe we can have a book talk on it a
book talk that one now there's an idea
and then we can have representative
woodcock give us the cliff notes we're
going to call it a tandy's talk and
uh
so i would appreciate it though if i i
found it to be uh
really quite eye-opening uh it
the school board meetings in bedford
have been
what i thought
rollicking compared to days gone by but
after reading this particular article
uh i realized that there are things
happening in communities all over the
state that i clearly was not aware of so
i share this
yeah i share this with you as an
eye-opening experience that i would not
all righty
um
uh
guys
everything
[Music]
you